so leute wir basteln jetzt noch mal zwei stunden rum bevor es dann bei allen weihnachten ist
guck mal sogar jesus ist da. immer man das so ausspricht weiß ich nicht. break it time
jesus jesus besucht uns persönlich heute auf dem channel da bin ich beruhigt. das passt
passend zu weihnachten. braucht ein update? ja nächstes jahr, nächstes jahr. das machen
wir dann wenn ich wenn ich dort öfters mal bin ja wenn ich paar tage da gewesen bin aber
leute passend zu weihnachten. break it genau. passend zu weihnachten habe ich meinen vertrag
unterschrieben. also ich hatte den vertrag ja die ganze zeit schon da und ich hätte ihn auch
unterschreiben können aber der vertrag war immer noch die ganze zeit vorbehaltlich dass der
betriebsrat zustimmt und heute habe ich post gekriegt dass der betriebsrat zugestimmt hat
das heißt jetzt ist es gültig. unterschrieben ist er schon. ja gut die haben wahrscheinlich
eine vereinbarung dass der betriebsrat sowohl bei neueinstellung als auch bei entlassung
irgendwie informiert werden muss. geh ich mal von aus. jetzt ist es official. jetzt ist das unter
dach und fach nächstes jahr erster vierter neuer job jetzt ist es auch gültig im endeffekt ja
für beide seiten und nächste woche dienstag oder mittwoch gehe ich dann nach frankfurt und
kündigung ist raus ich meine es ist schon natürlich viel knapper könnte es nicht sein bis spätestens
31.12 hätte das passieren müssen und das ist ein samstag also das ist eigentlich fast schon
auf den letzten drücker hier. ich mach mal die vm an. small access point auch am start
weil ich jetzt noch zeit hab zu streamen also ich muss in so 18 uhr gibts futter bei uns dann
müssen wir noch auf dem friedhof zum opa zu opa oma dann ist weihnachtsstells kram noch dann
muss ich heute abend noch ein bisschen mmo kreisel grind machen weil heute glaube ich den ganzen
tag die leute da sind mit denen ich mit denen ich sonst spiele aber ich will noch ein bisschen
basteln so ein bisschen vor dem ganzen weihnachtskram müssen wir noch ein bisschen weihnacht weiter
machen was abgeht wir machen bisschen google cloud konfigurations zeug weiter und keine sorge wenn
ihr im letzten stream nicht dabei wart ihr habt eigentlich nichts verpasst wir werden das noch
mal ordentlich neu machen und ich habe auch das was vom letzten mal da ist habe ich auch alles
gelöscht heilig abend ja klar warum nicht warum nicht bis 18 uhr 18 uhr spätestens 18 uhr ist
hapa hapa bei mir fortran nicht fortnight andere machen fortnight wir machen fortran nee nicht
wirklich also ehrlich gesagt es ist mir am liebsten von allen plattformen muss ich ehrlich sagen es
ist zwar auch total wir wo manche sachen sind aber ganz ehrlich rein vom web interface auch wenn das
das ist was man nicht so häufig verwendet wenn man die sachen irgendwie konfig management
technisch drin hat und so was aber rein vom web interface und darum empfinde ich persönlich
azure am besten aws sieht ein bisschen oldschool aus und die namen sind ganz merkwürdig da ist
identity service noch der beste aber aws habe ich auch am wenigsten von allen verwendet google
cloud ist so dazwischen google cloud also das web interface von google cloud ist quasi wie
so eine schlechte android app das ist material design ohne material design zu sein das ist quasi
schwarz weiß mit ab und zu meinem blauen button also ich finde in google cloud aus prinzip nie
was ich suche da immer ewig bei aws ist eigentlich ganz ok aber die dinger sind so wir benannt dass
du nicht weißt was damit gemeint ist insgesamt finde ich die kombination von bedienbarkeit
bezeichnungen und so was bei azure eigentlich am besten das dumme an azure ist nur dass microsoft
ganz gerne mal vier fünf sachen hat für die für das gleiche ja und vier fünf verschiedene
versionen für die für die gleichen sachen und manchmal hast du einen offiziellen docs noch
drinnen stehen so geht es aber das geht gar nicht mehr so und in der neuesten version vom
azure cli gibt es die option schon gar nicht mehr oder heißt jetzt anders oder so was azure
brauchen wir für alles ehrlich gesagt das erstellen und löschen von vms also von instances heißt
es ja heißt es ja warum auch immer sich bei google cloud sie gedacht haben virtual machine
ist ein doofes wort muss instance heißen dies dauert ja auch ewig das dauert teilweise zwei
minuten da was zu löschen dass da alles ewig braucht überall so was hältst du von diesem
c sharp buch angebot keine ahnung ob die was taugen dort net core 6 und angela das ja eine
kombination alter monka es das klingt vom titel ganz gut ob es was taugt weiß ich nicht dort
nehmen dort dort in den 7 klingt aktuell minimal ipis sind tatsächlich was interessantes neues
keine ahnung ob das was taugt schwer zu sagen also die meisten autoren sagen mir nichts die
bücher sagen mir nichts razor pages das nee ich weiß nicht ob man das braucht das klingt ganz
sinnig keine ahnung aber ultimate ultimate ultimate bundle vielleicht aber ultimate ist
das bestimmt nicht keine ahnung nix zu sagen ja wir basteln jetzt noch ein bisschen klau
technisch weiter das was wir das letzte mal angefangen haben ja aber wie gesagt ihr müsst
euch keine gedanken machen wenn ihr nicht dabei wart also wir machen das jetzt noch
mal ordentlich neu also ziel ist heute dass wir google cloud technisch automatisch vms aufbauen
können in gruppen us und eu also dass wir den back end service machen können dann ein benächsten streams
der sowohl in usa als auch in europa läuft plus dann in zukunft noch den htps in google htps
load balancer davor der das regional verteilt und wir nehmen nicht die fertige variante davon von
google sondern machen das selbst und ansonsten ist das ziel heute dass wir noch ein automatisch
automatisch den server ein bisschen konfigurieren nachdem er erstellt ist sowohl in gruppen einteilen
wie gesagt eu us dass wir internetverbindungen herstellen können von innen nach außen aber nicht
von außen nach innen also sprich dass die server package updates machen können und und dass sie
sich automatisch am monitoring registrieren beziehungsweise monitoring automatisch eingerichtet
wird mit den ip's der server sowas sowas in der richtung das stimmt aber es ist nicht wichtig
wenn man diesmal ist egal ob man es verpasst hat machen das eh noch mal ordentlich neu weil lesen
kann das eh keiner was hier das letzte mal was zum teufel sind wir mit rider los lesen kann das
ja keiner so richtig was hier verzapft habt das letzte mal gut ich meine das ist jetzt noch
übersichtlich lesbar aber da kommt ja noch ein bisschen was dabei welches monitoring wir machen
ganz cloud native style natürlich ein prometheus note exporter auf die kisten und machen da dann
prometheus als extra kiste wir machen eine monitoring kiste und die prometheus konfig
bauen wir uns dann automatisch aus den ip's der instances die wir angelegt haben zusammen würde
ich würde ich live so nicht verwenden ganz ehrlich da würde ich einen zentralen server verwenden
und irgendwie ein paar push gateways dazwischen aber jetzt hier zum basteln ist das ganz gut
grafana können wir lokal laufen lassen lokal ist grafana und da machen wir ein tunnel und
connecten uns da zu unserem prometheus beides beides ich brauche das und ich will ein bisschen
rumspielen brauchen tue ich das weil google cloud dort wo ich anfange am 1.4 wo ziemlich viel
verwendet wird und ich habe recht brauchbar plan von google cloud aber jetzt nicht so dass
ich sagen würde ich kann da quasi jeden tag gut gut alles drin machen deswegen gucke ich
mir das ein bisschen an jetzt die nächsten monate bis in terraform müssen wir uns auch
angucken auch weil wir heute nicht terraform verwenden sondern wir machen mit pulumi weiter
weil damit habe ich noch nicht so viel gemacht das wollte ich mir immer mal ein bisschen näher
angucken finden rein dankeschön für den sub so sieht es aus ja und und ganz ehrlich mir
macht es rumspielen ja spaß gachi bass deswegen für mich ist das ja keine arbeit in dem sinn
und was ich noch nicer finde ist es gibt ja nicht viele die so content machen auf twitch
oder sonst was in der richtung das ist letztendlich irgendwie den leuten auf twitch auch gefällt
ich meine das war jetzt ja auch nicht von anfang an so klar ja so ist das doch richtig
so zu weihnachten gratuliert man ja auch nicht aber zum neuen job kann man das machen also
ich bin wirklich happy dass das geklappt hat erstens also aus mehreren gründen ich kann
es einfach mal sagen ich bin aus mehreren gründen wirklich happy und auch das heute
geradezu das wirklich noch mal richtig schönes fast schon weihnachtsgeschenk ja dass das
gepa heute ich die bestätigung gekriegt habe alles jetzt zugestimmt jetzt ist es gültig
also aus mehreren gründen erstens kenne ich schon mal jemand dort wo ich hingehe von
früher dann nehme ich noch ein kollege mit dort hin von meiner aktuellen arbeit der mit
dem ich mich auch wirklich gut verstehe so dann haben die dort sinnvolle homeoffice regelung
mit einem tag die woche und also anwesenheit einen tag die woche und wenn was dazwischen
kommt auch mal 14 tage aber ein tag die woche finde ich vollkommen ok hätte ich auch jetzt
gesagt ist alles in ordnung aber mein aktueller arbeitgeber war ja der meinung er muss auf
mindestens 50 wenn nicht sogar zwei drittel in zukunft dann bestehen und sowas also es
gibt homeoffice und noch als bonus obendrauf nicht nur dass ich an sich schon richtig bock
hab darauf das zu machen was die dort was ich bis jetzt gehört habe ja also ich denke
da kann ich gerade dass ich gerne ich bastel ja gerne irgendwelche tools das haben wir
im stream auch schon gemacht für alles möglich glaube das bringt da wirklich was aber was
natürlich noch mal so der bonus obendrauf ist es gibt auch noch eine ganze ecke mehr
geld ich meine ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen ich verdiene dort quasi mit vier tagen bisschen
mehr als jetzt mit fünf tagen also wenn ich jetzt fünf tage arbeiten würde verdiene
ich quasi weniger als dort mit vier also ungefähr das gleiche ungefähr das ist schon wahnsinn
schau mal hock mehr geld ja
jetzt machen wir heute wir machen die google cloud geschichte weiter das hier nur dass
wir das jetzt mal ordentlich machen bin ich noch eingeloggt bin ich noch boin ich mach
das hier mal alles zu bin ich bin ich noch eingeloggt excellent hier easy ich bin nur
eingeloggt max s null hd 4k alles klar alles so fakescheiße wieder mal null hd 4k alles
klar und da sieht man schon wie random ich irgendwie über die tastatur geface rolled
bin beim erstellen dieses account würde voll gerne die zahlen wissen doch ich kann dir
das sagen also wenn es wenn ich wissen kann ich euch sagen das ist ja nichts geheimes
darf man darf man erzählen also ich kann dir nicht exakt die berechnung sagen da drin
da ist ja noch ein bisschen bonus und sowas dabei also ich kann es dir sagen also auf
fünf tage auf fünf tage gerechnet auf fünf tage für die klicks mache ich nächste woche
aber da sage ich nicht direkt das aber ich erzähle es dir die nun leider ich erzähle
es dir also auf fünf tage immer auf fünf tage auf fünf tage setzt sich mein gehalt
zusammen aus 92.000 euro fest und dann kommt noch bonus obendrauf der bonus ist abhängig
davon wie viel ziel wie man seine eigenen ziele erfüllt wie gut die it ihre ziele erfüllt
und wie gut es in der firma läuft also es gibt drei verschiedene boni und die die boni
gehen von quasi von der hälfte der zahlen die drauf steht bis zu mal 1,5 die zahlen
die drauf steht also sagen wir mal irgendwie ich glaube sind zwölf ich weiß es ich weiß
gar nicht genau ich weiß gar nicht genau zumindest da steht eine gewisse zahl drauf
als bonus und von dieser zahl denkt die kann es entweder mal 0,5 das ist das minimalste
geben oder mal 1,5 das ist das höchste und das ganze halt drei mal weil das jeweils
eigener erfolg erfolgt der abteilung erfolgt der firma ist und das schwankt dann also
ein bisschen und obendrauf kommt da noch mal kohle für rufbereitschaft das muss man beispielsweise
sieben mal im jahr machen ist aber kein problem ich meine jetzt eh vorm rechner und da kommt
auch mal ein bisschen was zusammen also insgesamt wird es wahrscheinlich so in dem das kommen
wir wie gesagt kommen bis auf den bonus an insgesamt alles in allem wird es wahrscheinlich
so um 105 bis 110 k irgendwie so in dem dreh sein genau kann ich es euch erst sagen wenn
ich ein jahr da war und die gehaltsabrechnung dann habe es gibt es gibt für so gut wie
alles zuschläge wie macht man den eigenen erfolg fest also soweit ich das verstanden
habe machst du am anfang des jahres oder am anfang deines aber jetzt beginnt dann machst
du für ein jahr lang ein plan oder so was mit deinem chef und danach richtet sich das
aber nachdem der chef ja auch ein gewisses interesse daran hat dass du das schaffst weil
dann steht er gut da wenn seine leute das alles immer super schaffen wird da wahrscheinlich
nix komplett haarsträumnis reingeschrieben damit nicht reingeschrieben der max kann
bis nächstes jahr cobalt würde ich sagen ja klar ich kann jetzt schon cobalt easy kein
problem und wer es mir nicht glaubt stream archiv link schicken massive cobalt skills
heute im video da waren wieder so ein paar leute wo ich mir gedacht habe die wissen einfach
nicht die wissen einfach nicht was sie schreiben
zum beispiel wo ist er denn zum beispiel der eine dude hier der geschrieben hat die passwörter
sind gehasht und nicht geliegt was auch immer du kannst secrets nicht haschen weil er könnte
sie ja nicht mehr entschlüsseln ok was hat er denn geantwortet ok ich glaube wirklich
nicht verstanden was es geht ja der hat h und h verwechsel so jetzt aus überstunden
oder gibt es irgendeine vereinbarung zu ich kann sie aus dem kopf so genau gar nicht sagen
ich glaube das kriegste aus bezahlt das kannst ja ne du musst die ne nicht ausbezahlen kannst
du dir nicht ich glaube die sollst du nehmen oder ich weiß es nicht mal gucken ich das
muss ich das weiß ich aus dem kopf alles so nicht
was könnte sowas beispielsweise sein oder ist das ja doch ich kann ein beispiel sagen
zum beispiel könnte man in einer so vereinbarung sagen die systeme die ein admin betreut sollen
mindestens 999 abtime haben das wäre zum beispiel sowas was man reinschreiben könnte natürlich
sollte man also ein kleines hinter türchen definieren weil es gibt ja durchaus auch
mal ausfälle da kann der admin nix für oder dass ich man macht einen cc na keine ahnung
das hängt wahrscheinlich sehr individuell von dem jeweiligen job ab ich bin mal gespannt
was da was da rauskommt also ein bestandteil wird auf jeden fall wahrscheinlich systemstabilität
sein das hat er mir auf dem vorstellungsgespräch schon angekündigt ja genau der tickets aber
reaktionszeiten tatsächlich ist es gut wenn es ist für beide seiten gut wenn es was
ist was sinnvoll überprüfbar ist weil dann kann im endeffekt dann auch keiner kommen
sagen ist doch nicht so aber kurz die vm an an die vm ist noch an lull lull hd xd archlinux
keyring schon wieder auf auf was will er dann wieder updaten man hat hier tägliche updates
docker wird geupdatet aber dann ja genau so was in der richtung ja aber das machen die
aber auch nicht um es zu verschlüsseln das machen die das sonderzeichen in den password
dann keine probleme machen wenn die base 64 encoded nicht irgendwie um die sicherer zu
machen weil ein base 64 encoded das password ist ja immer noch klartext in dem sinn du
musst es halt base 64 decode was sieht es aus und wir haben jetzt auch gleich 18 uhr
um zwei stunden zeit was sinnvolles zu machen da sollten wir doch was auf die reihe kriegen
denke ich also ich zeige euch jetzt mal für alle die im letzten stream nicht dabei waren
was wir gemacht haben und dann was wir heute verbessern und dann ist weihnachts hapa hapa
angesagt was gibt es zu futtern heute bei dir bratapfel gibt es auf jeden fall hinten
drauf und davor gibt es baguette mit also bisschen was leichteres tatsächlich werde
ich mich gar nicht ich werde mich ultra voll fressen aber nichts mit super fettigem so
was ist so hackfleisch hackfleisch klöße mit irgendwie so spezialsoße frag mich nicht
und baguette dabei da kann ich mich auch immer richtig voll fressen von danach gibt es bratapfel
und dann morgen gibt es richtig fett pepo fett morgen gibt es hirsch darf man den veganer
nicht sagen ja ok aber morgen gibt es hirsch könnte auch re sein ich sag aber hirsch
das ist abfuck teuer
kennst du die militante veganerin da gibt es bestimmt ein paar oder
oder meinst du die die in den innenstädten rum rennt und jeden fragt bist du schon vegan
und ja ja die kenne ich die kenne ich ist ja bei solchen leuten ist das problem gar
nicht das was sie sagen weil das was sie sagen ist oftmals gar nicht so unlogisch
und so und so falsch ja die art und weise wie das gesagt wird schreckt aber einfach
viele leute ab und überzeugt niemand also die könnten noch so viel sinnvolle sachen
auf die art und weise wie es gesagt wird sind die leute provozierte damit eher
irgendwelche trotzreaktionen dass die leute sagen und jetzt fresse ich erst recht irgendwie
drei schnitzel in der woche was sie was sie sagen ist gar nicht mal so verkehrt also ich
kann mich ja prinzipiell mit dem gedanken an sich durchaus auch anfreunden nur dass ich den
graben halt gerne ist das ist das problem was ich habe so die aussage dahinter finde ich
eigentlich ganz sinnig 17 monat dankeschön für den sub so wo sind wir stehen geblieben
so jetzt haben wir alles geupdatet gut also ich zeige euch noch mal was wir das letzte
mal gemacht haben und dann löschen wir das und machen das ordentlich machen das ordentlich
neu also wir haben uns das letzte mal ein bisschen beschäftigt mit der google cloud
und mein dark reader spielt verrückt ok wir haben uns das letzte mal ein wenig beschäftigt
mit der google cloud das was ich hier seht ist
viel besser viel besser gleich leute viel besser wird man schon gar nicht wird man nicht mehr
blind wenn man den kram aufgemacht hatte ein bisschen größer dass ihr was sehen könnt
also wir haben uns das letzte mal ein bisschen mit google cloud beschäftigt was ihr hier
seht ist das web interface von google cloud so sieht das aus und wir verwenden dafort
also google hat wirklich gott und die welt gibt es da sogar jesus gibt es da irgendwo
in den untermenüs alles also passen zu weihnachten gibt es gibt es alles vom weihnachtsmann bis
zum osterhass es ist alles irgendwo hier in irgendwelchen untermenüs ist das drinne
alter wie lahm das mit dem dark reader ist das web interface das problem ist nur du findest
bei google cloud nichts und wir verwenden nur den teil der sich compute engine nennt
und computers können wir übrigens an der stelle auch detachment hier und sonst was
der sich compute engine nennt und compute engine kannst du unter anderem vms anlegen
also ganz normale virtualisierte server das ist richtig richtig langsam damit so und was
wir jetzt gemacht haben ist folgendes wir haben uns eine kleine server umgebung aufgebaut
mit vms in der google cloud unter anderem verteilt auf mehrere instanzen in europa
und in den usa und darauf lief ein webserver mit einer testseite das war es alles also
nix nix dolles ich kann euch mal zeigen wie das ganze aussieht gleich wir können das
was ich das letzte mal gemacht habe gleich nochmal anschmeißen was kostet das rein
für vms ist google cloud viel zu teuer für acht vms für acht kleine vms mit mit ips
bezahlst du irgendwie 84 dollar im monat oder viel zu teuer wenn du bei hetzner guckst
kriegst du den gleichen kram für 20 euro also rein für vms lohnt sich das nicht es
lohnt sich generell nur wenn man noch weitere services haben will bei diesem anbieter ja
wenn man beispielsweise die globale loadbalancing funktion verwenden will oder noch ein kubanades
cluster hat oder google google maps und zeug verwendet storage geschichten und sonstige
sachen dann lohnt sich das wenn man einfach nur virtuelle server braucht dann ist das
overkill dann würde ich zum anderen anbieter gehen neben hetzner könnte man auch noch
kontabo nennen das ist richtig aber kontabo sponsort mich nicht ganz einfach wobei mich
hetzner aktuell auch nicht sponsort aber sie haben es schon gemacht moin chanel ich bin
wie gesagt ich bin nur zwei stunden da das heißt wir müssen was auf die reihe kriegen
genau das ist das web interface von google cloud so sieht das ganze aus wer so nicht
gesehen hat jetzt habt das gesehen wie gesagt die untermenüs hier sind heftig also es gibt
wirklich alles leco dankeschön für den sub gar nicht gesehen durch scrollen ja so und
also das nächste ist wenn man sachen wie google cloud verwendet oder auch die hetzner cloud
aber da ist es nicht ganz so wild aber wenn man sowas verwendet wie aws azure google cloud
hetzler leno digital ocean dann ist das auf der einen seite ganz gut wenn sie ein sinnvolles
web interface haben da kann man nämlich mal schnell was drin erstellen aber sobald man
ein bisschen was größeres komplexeres und und umfangreicheres drin macht ist das keine
gute idee die sachen im web interface zusammenzuklingen stellt euch mal vor ich möchte beispielsweise
eine web anwendung hosten eine web anwendung die besteht aus datenbank einem webserver
fürs frontend backend logik net domain zertifikaten dns einträgen ein netzwerk dazwischen sowas
also da gehört ein bisschen was dazu und wenn ich das alles übers web interface zusammenklicken
will dann geht das bin ich aber eine weile mit beschäftigt es ist fehler anfällig und
wenn ich was ändern will hat keiner meine ahnung was passiert ist deswegen gibt es so
tools wie zum beispiel polumi oder terraform terraform ist das bekanntere muss man sagen
oder bicep biceps bicep ich glaube bicep heißt das ist die geschichte von microsoft für
etwa da definiert man in in im textfile da definiert man auf irgendeine art und weise
was angelegt werden soll oder hat man einen config management tool was das für einen
macht und das sieht dann zum beispiel so aus ja wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt meine backends
meine meine backendserver erstellen will für meine web anwendung dann könnte ich hier
zum beispiel sagen ich will ein netzwerk anlegen ich will eine firewall anlegen das nur port
80 und port 22 rein darf incoming direction können übrigens hier auch reinschreiben
können auch direction in bauen schreiben aber braucht man nicht weil das hier oder ingress
wenn weiß ich was gar nicht was bei directions was da erlaubt ist zeigt man ja lass mal die
hilfe gucken ingress ok genau also dass es eingehend ist was aber egal ist weil eingehend
ist der default dass man eine firewall anlegen und dass wir zum beispiel jetzt hier vier
webserver anlegen oder nicht vier webserver stimmt ja jetzt wir legen vier linuxserver
an also von null bis vm count das ist vier wir legen vier linuxserver an die heißen
webapp null eins zwei drei vier die werden sowohl abwechselnd einmal in eu angelegt und
dann in den usa angelegt als betriebssystem verwenden wir ubuntu 22 04 und nachdem die
kiste gestartet ist gibt es noch ein mini script was läuft nämlich da sind die packages
updated die neuesten updates installiert und einen engine x mit einer testseite darauf
installiert und wir haben noch netzwerk config dass die server nämlich das netzwerk was
wir hier oben angelegt haben wo die eingehende firewall ist benutzen und das war es und wenn
ich das jetzt ausführe zeige ich zeige euch das mal kurz dass es funktioniert jetzt ausführer
dann macht ein bisschen was und jetzt sagt er ok ich habe jetzt deinen aktuellen zustand
von deiner cloud analysiert und festgestellt ich müsste das hier machen dass alles da
ist das heißt ich muss netzwerk anlegen eine firewall anlegen und vier vms anlegen soll
ich das machen dann sage ich ja und dann dauert es jetzt ein zwei minuten und dann habe ich
die umgebung exakt so da wie ich das ganze hier definiert hat so macht man das heutzutage
hauptsächlich zum größten teil mit terraform terraform ist eigentlich das bekanntere tool
aber ich wollte mich mal mit der sache hier auseinandersetzen weil ich das vom ansatz
her cooler finde als terraform habe ich schon gesagt habe ich dann habe ich schon wieder
verdrängt würde hier auch ansible funktionieren ich verstehe nie was deklarativ bedeutet der
unterschied zwischen deklarativ und ich weiß gar nicht was das gegenstück ist imperat nie
prozedural was ist das gegenstück zu deklarativ leute wer ist von euch wer weiß es ich weiß
aus dem kopf nicht vielleicht weiß jemand von euch damit ist gemeint dass du nicht hinschreibst
was du genau machen willst in welcher reinfolge sondern dass du den endzustand prozedural
imperativ ja was denn du also deklarativ bedeutet du beschreibst den endzustand wie es sein
soll und das tool bringt das dann in diese konfiguration ohne dass du definieren musst
wie es das genau macht also hier sage ich ja auch nur terraform ist deklarativ ja genau
hier sage ich ja auch nur ich will wobei das hier schon wieder so ein zwischending ist
ja weil polumi hat ja eine echte kann ein richtig vollständige programmier sprache
verwenden aber im prinzip ist es auch noch relativ deklarativ ja du sagst ich hätte
gerne vm mit dem typ mit mit dem betriebssystem drauf mit den netzwerk konfig und dann sage
ich leg an wie es das macht ist mir eigentlich relativ egal ja und wie ist das jetzt mit
der firewall und im netzwerk verknüpft ist mir auch egal ich sage da nicht als erstes
führe das kommando create network aus danach attach firewall attach instance create instance
und ich sage einfach ich will diese drei dinge haben mach mal und natürlich bei polumi
ist es so dass es nicht rein deklarativ ist weil ich kann das ganze halt immer noch in
der vollständigen fall ist jetzt hier sie schab in einer ordentlichen programmier sprache
programmieren das heißt man kann eigentlich das beste aus allen welten verbinden das ist
auch der grund warum ich mir polumi ein bisschen mehr angucken wollte weil ich es vom ansatz
her ziemlich nice finde so ok es ist fertig er hat unsere konfig angelegt und wenn ich
jetzt ins webfront end gehe und aktualisieren drücke dann sehen wir nach dem google cloud
abfahrt langsam ist dann sehen wir ach guck mal da wir haben jeweils zwei backends zwei
stück in eu und zwei stück in us west 1 ja genau ansible würde hier auch funktionieren
wobei man sagen muss ansible und terraform und polumi die haben unterschiedliche schwerpunkte
also so provisioning tools wie terraform sind dafür da deine infrastruktur anzulegen
als zu professionieren also sprich erstelle 10 vms erstelle den load balancer erstelle
den mit dem ubuntu image und ab der stelle sind diese tools eigentlich fertig wenn du
dann deine erstellten vms noch weiter konfigurieren willst dann machst du das meistens dann mit
einem config management tool sowas wie ansible also kannst beides mit beidem so ein bisschen
machen sieht man ja hier auch guck also ich lege hier den server an und ich habe noch
so eine mini konfiguration ja ich habe einen startup script was den webserver installiert
und die pakete updated wenn man jetzt den server komplexer konfigurieren muss ja zum
beispiel datenbank installieren ssh keys verteilen verzeichnisse anlegen monitoring agents installieren
und sowas dann wäre diese script wahrscheinlich nicht so lang sondern deutlich länger bis
das fertig ist ja und an der stelle wäre es dann sinnvoll hier drinnen zu sagen ok
starte einfach ansible playbook und mach mit ansible deine config weiter
deshalb unterschiedliche schwerpunkte mit ansible konfigurierst du deine kisten und
mit terraform professionierst du die kisten und nicht nur nicht nur vms du kannst dann
mit terraform und polumi so ziemlich alles machen was die jeweiligen cloud plattformen
hergeben also du kannst damit auch irgendwelche serverless functions anlegen oder du kannst
damit load balancer anlegen hdps services und sowas in der richtung du kannst mit ansible
das auf der anderen seite auch machen aber es hat die frage wo der schwerpunkt liegt
der schwerpunkt bei ansible liegt eindeutig auf server konfiguration und der schwerpunkt
bei terraform liegt bei infrastruktur professionierung und wenn du beides zusammen verwendest machst
es nicht verkehrt bei kleinigkeiten es gibt natürlich auch gewisse überschneidung also
hier für diese drei zeilen server konfig brauche ich kein ansible playbook das ist
hier inline vollkommen ok da brauche ich auch keine extra datei aber wenn es größer
wird kann man sich glaube ich denken es ist keine allzu gute idee mehr das bauen wir
vielleicht auch in einem der nächsten streams oben vielleicht machen wir noch ein bisschen
ansible dabei also wenn ich mir eine dockermaschine baue professioniere ich über polumi terraform
ja das kannst du machen also wenn du zum beispiel durch ich gehe mal davon aus du willst
ein docker image bauen lassen ja also docker docker in irgendeine docker registry du willst
ein image bauen lassen in docker registry pushen oder oder keine ahnung weiß ich nicht
was du was du vor hast wobei ich das über github actions oder so machen will aber prinzipiell
also es geht hier nicht um dockermaschine in dem fall geht es hier um eine echte vm in
der cloud gibt aber auch module für kuppane des deployments und so was aber gehen wir
jetzt mal streichen wir mal docker setzen wir immer hier vm ein dann ist das so genau du
professionierst die über polumi terraform biceps oder was es nicht nur alles sonst gibt
für tools du sagst was das haben soll du legst dns einträge netzwerk an also in du professionierst
dann quasi damit keine einzelnen vms sondern du hast dann quasi so ein peil wo du halt
quasi deinen service definierst der service kann bestehen aus einer datenbank drei backend
vms und im load balancer und so was ja das würdest du professionieren über terraform
und polumi netzwerk ein du machst netzwerk dns einträge und wenn du mit cloud in it
auskommst brauchst du auch kein ansatz mehr also wenn du beispielsweise cloud in it benutzt
um nach start up packages zu updaten kannst ja machen dass sie upgrade packages update
packages wenn du mit cloud in it auskommst du kannst den cloud in it ja auch noch irgendwie
zwei drei zeilen custom user script reinschreiben dann reicht das voll und ganz aus dann brauchst
kein ansatz also könntest zum beispiel über terraform deine kiste professionieren lassen
und darauf dann cloud in it laufen lassen package updates machen docker installieren
lassen und dann bist du fertig du brauchst kein ansatz mehr also aus welchen gründen
du das haben willst weiß ich jetzt ja nicht aber das könntest du machen dann brauchst
kein ansatz mehr wenn du jetzt allerdings also prinzipiell brauchst du ansatz nie kannst
auch alles mit bash scripts machen du kannst aber auch puppet verwenden chef oder irgendein
anderes config tool aber ansatz soll stack oder sowas ansatz ist halt zurzeit einfach
nur relativ beliebt was das angeht ich finde es auch persönlich von den ganzen config management
tools am besten aber wenn du jetzt deine deine deine vm in der cloud professioniert hast über
terraform und du willst da noch viel mehr drauf machen du willst da zum beispiel eine
postgres installieren du willst ein webserver installieren du willst ssh keys verteilen
dass die ganzen entwickler sich darauf einloggen können du brauchst zertifikat du brauchst
die passenden verzeichnisse mit den passenden berechtigung du brauchst so in den share dass
die leute was runter kopieren können also wenn du quasi nicht so eine mini kiste hast
rein für deine anwendung sondern halt so ein ganz klassischer linux server der halt bisschen
umvergleicher ist dann ist es sinnvoll sowas in ansible nachträglich zu machen nach dem professionieren
ja weil sonst hätte er jetzt ja quasi in riesen extra script in einem cloud in noch drinne stehen
gedanken gang ist dass man eventuell noch einen kubernetes werke hochzieht falls die anderen
am limit sind ja da gibt es auch wenn ihr schon ein kubernetes hast dafür gibt es ja viele viele
ach so ein neuer du willst meist komplett neuer werken not ja das könnte man zum beispiel machen
das ist so gut ja genau ja dafür ist das wunderbar genau da ist ich glaube das ist sogar eines der
gründe wofür es mal ursprünglich erfunden wurde ja genau ein weiterer werkenau das ist ein super
beispiel dafür du stellst fest irgendwie deine infrastruktur ist am limit und was weiß ich
pewdiepie hat ein service zufällig mal bei sich in einem youtube video gezeigt dass es einen
riesen ansturm da könntest du einfach weitere werkenau zu professionieren darüber genau die
sich komplett selbstständig konfigurieren in den cluster einklinken das kannst du darüber machen
wenn du kein komplett managt ding hast du könntest du könntest sogar noch viel weiter gehen du
könntest auch insofern automatisieren dass du sagst hey mein mein load balancer ist über
einem gewissen connection connection limit oder meine meine werkenauts haben alle 80 prozent cpu
auslastung ich provisioniere jetzt mal neue dass da sind ja der automatisierungs fantasie keine
grenzen gesetzt du kannst theoretisch ganz abgedrehte sachen machen du kannst sogar gibt
sogar tools für du kannst traffic analysieren nee das machst du nicht direkt in terraform da
brauchst du irgendwie wobei ich nicht ausschließen würde dass es da nicht sogar auch mittlerweile
irgendwelche module für terraformen gibt nee das müsstest du anderweitig triggern über terraform
würdest du das professionieren machen aber das triggern von diesem professionieren müsstest du
dann über irgendwelche monitoring geschichten machen die eben feststellen ok meine connection
sind jetzt über 40.000 aber was du auch machen kannst was wirklich richtig cool ist was ich aber
so noch nie selbst gebaut habe viele cloud anbieter bieten das aber schon fix und fertig an google
zum beispiel auch google bietet zum beispiel load balancer an die dann backend services rauf und
runterskalieren können anhand der cpu auslastung und in verbindung man kann das aber auch alles
selbst bauen aber was richtig cool ist habe ich letztens auf github was gesehen ein tool was
deinen monatlichen traffic verlauf analysiert natürlich high IQ machine learning shit was
jetzt zur zeit angesagt ist und das kann dann dir voraussagen ob du nicht vielleicht jetzt schon
neue worker nodes professionieren sollst weil deine historischen daten zeigen dass in einem
tag wahrscheinlich mehr benutzer drauf zugreifen werden so weit sind wir schon leute das ist
richtig abgedrehter shit was man da mittlerweile machen kann ob man der sache dann so weit traut
dass man das komplett ohne beaufsichtigung professionieren und und löschen lässt sei
mal dahingestellt aber zumindest das feststellen und zumindest vielleicht den monitor eine warnung
anzeigen reicht ja schon ja also wenn es ein bisschen größere service ist man so ein tool
hat und das tool dann sagt hey guck mal achtung warning im monitoring wahrscheinlich haben wir
bald einen benutzer andrang dann kann es dann kann die monitoring meldung sich ja in admin
schnappen kann theoretisch ein automatisches ticket sogar erzeugen bitte bitte auf empfehlung
zwei neue worker nodes professionieren macht er das also da sind das ist wirklich richtig cooles
zeug was man damit machen kann also sind ja da wie gesagt da sind der administrations und
automatisierungs fantasie kaum grenzen gesetzt was man da fabrizieren kann mittlerweile mit
also wirklich wirklich mega nice und wenn man sowas halt nicht selbst bauen will und so was
fertig benutzen möchte da sind die großen cloud service ist halt richtig gut weil die haben so
was alle ja zum beispiel hat laut balancer zum beispiel hat google auch so was eingebaut du
kannst beispielsweise in google alter ist das lahm mann du kannst den google htps laut balancer
guckt euch das mal an du kannst die google htps laut balancer verwenden das liegt am
dark reader wahrscheinlich dass es so langsam ist du kannst beispielsweise den den den htps
laut balancer service verwenden von google und der kann zum beispiel so predict der kann
beispielsweise predikten wie dein benutzer antrag ist und daraufhin schon neue services
im vorfeld starten also wenn du beispielsweise eine analyse laufen hast die festgestellt hat
hey jeden dritten donnersdag im monat hast du erhöhtes benutzer aufkommen dann kann es dir
dann quasi schon donners nach morgen um acht uhr neue notes professionieren weil das voraussagen
kann dass es heute wieder passiert das ist richtig abgedrehter kram
das verstehe ich jetzt nicht genau deswegen hat terraform den vorteil gegenüber an so dass man
ganze pakete module rausnehmen kann das ist richtig das geht beendet ja nicht weil er würde ab einem
gewissen punkt an etwas nicht funktionieren also das ist das ist richtig aber ich sagen muss so
große installationen dass das ein großes problem geworden ist kenne ich mich aber mit pappet
kenne ich also wir benutzen ja schon langjährig pappet dort wo ich jetzt arbeite deswegen kann
ich das einfach mal annehmen dass es mit end simple auch ein problem ist also stell euch mal
vor ihr habt ein server konfig management was eure server einrichtet konfiguriert nachdem sie
erstellt wurden ja ssh keys drauf kopiert verzeichnisse anlegt user anlegt services
installiert pakete installiert so was stelle ich mal vor ihr habt das und ihr wollt jetzt ihr
habt beispielsweise dort drin stehen es soll ein verzeichnis angelegt werden auf jedem server
auf jedem server soll soll etc wo bloß keckel angelegt werden so das habt ihr definiert dass
dieses verzeichnis er hätte das gedacht dass es nicht da deshalb den konfig management definiert
dass das angelegt werden soll wenn ihr das jetzt auf aus eurem konfig management raus
nehmt dann ist es ja auf den server wurde schon ausgeführt wurde ja schon da und so tools wie
pappet haben mit entfernten sachen richtig probleme weil du hast in deinem konfig management drin
stehen bitte legt dieses verzeichnis an dann wirfst du das raus und dann ist das immer noch weiterhin
auf den server da weil wo er soll das konfig management wissen es wurde vorher angelegt
und jetzt muss es gelöscht werden das kennt es einfach nicht mehr und ignoriert dann hast du dann
ganz viel reste auf deinen system das problem hast du bei terraform und polumi nicht wobei
du halt solche sachen da drinne auch die verzeichnisse da drinne auch gar nicht konfigurieren
kannst aber auf infrastrukturebene hast du das problem nicht weil sowohl polumi als auch terraform
einen eine state datenbank haben also die merken sich was angelegt wurde von dem aktuellen schritt
zum jetzt geänderten deiner geänderten konfig und dann wissen die auch ok es wurde entfernt
das heißt ich muss das was ich im vorherigen schritt angelegt gelegt habe jetzt löschen
damit das system in den gewünschten zustand kommt die infrastruktur in gewünschten zustand kommt
ja das ist richtig was du machen kannst ist also bei ein simple bin ich mir da nicht ganz
sicher wohl gemerkt was du machen kannst ist du kannst in den ganzen konfig management tools
explizit definieren das was entfernt werden soll kannst bei pappet zum beispiel sagen ok
ich stelle das verzeichnis jetzt auf absent anstatt auf wie heißt das pappet
enabled ne created heißt glaube ich weiß gar im kopf gar nicht das kannst du machen aber
hast du den kram halt immer noch in einer konfig drinne obwohl du eigentlich willst
das verzeichnis weg ist und wenn du kein konfig management hast mit einer state datenbank die
sich merkt was es gemacht hat dann hast du immer die gleichen probleme und da weiß ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht wie das bei ansible ist ich wüsste nicht dass ansible eine lokale state datenbank
hat mit solchen steps hat es das wenn wir es neu hat es nicht
dann hast du dann hast du so probleme ja genau
ok was ich weiß nicht worauf sich das bezieht ist das tool nur für cloud platform oder
auch privat recht ist für alles die ursprüngliche idee ist damit cloud platform zu professionieren
aber es gibt ja provider für nahezu alles also wie gesagt digital ocean hetsner die
großen aws aber du kannst auch kvm vms damit anlegen oder wie heißt diese rettet virtualisierung
noch mal o wird war das o wird ne ah keine ahnung oder open stack und solche geschichten
du kannst auch eigene sachen damit betanken was geht
wüsste ich mal suchen auf github ich keine ahnung aber du kannst davon ausgehen allein
schon weil google sowas anbietet für ihre für ihre load balancer dass sie wahrscheinlich
irgendwas benutzen was es gibt oder sie haben selbst was entwickelt
muss man gucken traffic traffic prediction github traffic forecasting heißt traffic forecasting
das ist das ist für verkehr mit autos das damit nicht gewalt aber sowas gibt es auch
für netzwerk traffic taxi und bike lull rinzo dankeschön für den sub ja so also weiter
im text ein bisschen bisschen rumgeschwätzt also das ist das was ich letzte mal hier konfigurationstechnisch
angelegt habe ja es werden zwei backend systeme erstellt für europa und zwei backend systeme
für us west und es wird netzwerk und firewall erstellt port 80 und port 22 so weiterer punkt
von solchen konfig tools ist es wurden jetzt ganz viele sachen hier in der cloud angelegt
ja vms netzwerke firewall und wenn ich das alles wieder löschen will sage ich einfach
polumi oder terraform ist in dem fall egal destroy also der jeweilige befehl dann er
sagt mir ok du willst das komplette ding wieder löschen sage ich ja und jetzt ist alles wieder
rückstandslos weg das natürlich nice äußerst weihnachtliche musik ja so jetzt löscht er
das ganze gut jetzt können wir weitermachen chat gibt es noch ich habe jetzt sehr langen monolog
gehalten gibt es noch irgendwas oder wollte noch irgendwas dazu wissen oder irgendwelche details
oder was auch immer ja auf schieß los wenn wir schon dabei sind gib alles gatschi bus
ich muss mal kurz ich muss mal kurz fack warte mal ich muss mal kurz in meine melz melz gucken
so low-level konfig geschichten in lgm mache ich nicht selbst keine ahnung ich benutze den kram nur
muss mich noch nie um solche low-level-geschichten kümmern irgendwelche
konfig für den cluster ihr dhl paket wird gleich zugestellt da habe ich meine zweier für dhl
ach nee war gestern schon peck wait
das ist eine gute frage woher das meine lokale maschine weiß ich habe mal sowohl
ich habe vor vor feiner ahnung zwei jahren mark jubes etl und lenz eingerichtet
vielleicht habe ich das damals gemacht ich habe keine ahnung ich habe keine ahnung mehr
kubernetes handling ist so eine sache für sich ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass ich da den ultra
mega plan habe vom gesamten kubernetes ökosystem aber mal gucken wie sie im neuen job wird ich
glaube die machen bisschen bisschen bisschen mehr kubernetes als jetzt das heißt kann durchaus sein
dass ich da in einem halben jahr richtig richtig gut durchblicke ok alles klar weiter geht es so
also ich habe euch jetzt ja gezeigt was er hier angelegt hat die vier vms verteilt auf eu und
us und mittlerweile sollten die auch wieder weg sein wenn das mit dem löschen funktioniert hat
ja also ziel für heute ist dass wir das ordentlicher machen dass wir automatisches
monitoring aufsetzen mit prometo ist wo sich die haus registrieren bzw der monitoring haus die
anderen backends discovered dann teilen wir alles in gruppen ein sowohl eine gruppe für us und
eine gruppe für eu und wir richten ein dass die systeme ins internet kommen weil aktuell
kommen die systeme nämlich noch gar nicht ins internet und können keine package updates machen
der einzige weg wie die systeme ins internet kommen es aktuell wenn jedes system eine eigene externe
ip bekommt und das ist natürlich nicht sinn und zweck der sache erstens kostet das geld und
zweitens ist natürlich blödsinnig jedes system im internet hängen zu haben was man eigentlich gar
nicht im internet hängen haben will das heißt wir machen das jetzt mal ein bisschen wir machen
das jetzt mal ein bisschen ordentlicher ich würde sagen wir lagern das alles mal ein bisschen aus
also wir haben hier im prinzip zwei parts wir haben den part der netzwerk config also netzwerk
firewall später noch nut routing und so was und wir haben den part der server server konfiguration
und da brauchen wir zwei server typen wir brauchen einmal den server typ für die web für die web
anwendung und wir brauchen den server typ für das monitoring also will ich sagen wir machen mal so
was wie ich habe mir schon ein bisschen was vorbereitet wo ich abgucken kann wie ich den
ganzen graben nennen werde wir machen das mal ein bisschen ordentlicher ja ich wir machen jetzt
zum beispiel mal so eine klasse sowas wie in die netzwerk setup und oder weiß ich die weiß ich
jetzt die volumi component sie schafft da muss ich mir ein example zu angucken wie das funktioniert
hat component resources genau die scherbe aha excellent netzwerk set up component resource
netzwerk set up string name das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich ja brauche ich brauche keine
options options sind overrated outdated jebaited was auch immer das sein soll my component alles
klar so wir machen eine eigene klasse dass es ein bisschen schöner ist für für die ganzen
netzwerkgeschichten das heißt wir schnappen uns das hier und packen das da rein sollte an
der stelle noch kein problem machen und dann sagen wir oben anstatt das inline zu machen in der
main mit uns sagen wir um einfach keine netzwerk gleich new so was dann übergeben wir name
name ja das ist auch so ein bisschen glaubensfrage wie man seine seine cloud ressourcen benennt wir
machen wir es jetzt einfach mal so string hier name kw unser service ist der kw service einverstanden
und dann kriegen im prinzip alle ressourcen den namen von dem service weil aus der ressource
selbst geht ja hervor was es ist also ob es jetzt ein router ist oder den oder den vm oder sowas
das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich noch dabei schreiben so netzwerk setup brauchen wir legen
wir das an das wird minimiert das lagern wir nämlich auch gleich aus das hier unten brauchen
wir gar nicht netzwerk setup das ist gut mehr brauchen wir da nicht dann was brauchen wir
denn aus unserem netzwerk für infos um server aufzubauen die netzwerk id das heißt die muss
ich da irgendwie exportieren irgendwie mal extra netzwerk das war dass das ganze bisschen
ordentlicher ist das heißt ich habe es falsch rum gemacht null jetzt aber meine güte gut
sehr schön so jetzt kann ich da drauf zugreifen id sollte immer noch funktionieren ok jetzt
haben wir das ganze schon ein bisschen ordentlicher gemacht und jetzt machen wir fürs anlegen
von den server machen wir auch noch machen wir auch noch in extra in extra klasse aber
bevor wir das machen muss ich mir erstmal überlegen wie wir das am besten anlegen also
bevor wir es schön machen machen wir es erstmal funktional dass also dass es funktioniert
das werde ich mir alles löschen also ziel ist folgendes wir wollen lassen wir das mal
mit eu und so mal raus also wir wollen zwei server haben beziehungsweise hier anzahl der
vms also mal zwei oder ein zum test reicht dann geht schneller ja wenn man gar keine
schnittmenge damit hat was klaus services und aktuelle sachen was linux und server und
sowas angeht dann kann ich verstehen dass absolut kein durchblick hat aber schön dass du dann
wie ich hier gefunden her gefunden hast vielleicht machen wir ja nächsterzeit auch mal irgendwas
was dir was sagt also wir legen jetzt die wir legen jetzt einzelne server an mit ubuntu
wir haben jetzt so ein komisches skript am anfang das schenke ich mir jetzt mal ganz
ganz schnell also also folgende idee folgende idee und wenn ich muss hier irgendwas reinschreiben
anscheinend ok echo 123 beste startup script echo ajaja also idee ist jetzt folgendes
was ich was ich mir überlegt habe also ich möchte mehrere backendserver aufbauen hier
wird gestreamt ja eineinhalb stunden noch ich möchte mehrere backendserver aufbauen
und jetzt will ich ein system zum überwachen dieser backendserver installieren und dieses
system soll gleich beim aufbauen die ip adressen der systeme hier mit bekommen die wir angelegt
haben dies überwachen soll das heißt irgendwie muss ich jetzt die ip raus bekommen von dieser
angelegten instance also das heißt hier legen wir hier legen wir die eigentlichen server
an und jetzt will ich noch mal das ganze machen allerdings deswegen wäre das sinnvoll wenn
man das in der klasse auslager allerdings nur noch einmal ob es habe ich gar nicht genug
mit kopiert ja war vor m bis wohin geht denn das da jetzt will ich das noch mal machen
alles nicht vor m sondern wenn wir das mal irgendwie sich für ein wir nennen es backend
server da weiß man auch was damit gemeint ist und das hier nehmen wir nennen wir monitor
und server so und das ding heißt auch nicht web ab sondern das heißt lasst mal überlegen
das heißt so wie der name des projekts backends backend minus i das ist gut weil da können
wir nämlich die das monitoring system genauso nennen allerdings ohne zahl hinten dran und
doch wir können es wir können es null nennen weil es halt nur eins gibt haben wir so mindestens
einheitliches namensschema noch dran also das gibt monitor nicht backends sondern monitoring
monitoring server der rest können wir alles gleich lassen das ist ok so und jetzt ist
die große preisfrage weil du weh das kann hier auch raus jetzt ist die große preisfrage
ich setze hier zwei server auf oder ich setze hier ein server 2 ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoller
ich setze hier zwei server auf wie bekomme ich jetzt die ip dieser server hier in die
info für dieses system rein da bin ich bisschen ich habe mir extra polumi tutorials durchgelesen
ich glaube ich habe so großartig gecheckt ich habe ich habe es aber nicht so großartig
gecheckt also was man was man machen kann ist folgendes an diesem backendserver also
an jeder vm die man über die google cloud anlegt nachdem sie angelegt wurde kann man
sich zum beispiel die network interfaces anschauen und in den network interfaces sagen wir zum
beispiel keine first das erste netzwerk interface das war mega das war mega durch die brust
ins auge gemacht vom ersten netzwerk interface kann ich jetzt die network ip mir rausholen
genau so ging das und ich habe mir extra ein tutorial durchgelesen warum das so umständlich
ist und ich versuche ich das jetzt mal zu erklären warum das warum das so umständlich
ist also hier ist ja nur die konfiguration dass ich gerne einen server anlegen würde
zum zeitpunkt wo das hier ausgeführt wird ist das ist ist die vm also eine instance
ist quasi eine virtuelle maschine in der google cloud warum auch immer die instance genannt
wird zu der zu dem zeitpunkt wo ich diese konfig hier ausführe also dieses kript hier
ausführen das program hier ausführen ist die ja noch gar nicht fertig erstellt und
hat noch gar keine ip deswegen ist network interfaces auch keinen auch kein array eben
mit den informationen über alle netzwerk interfaces dieser vm sondern ein output so
und ein output ist quasi in pulumi das gleiche oder was ähnliches wie ein task in dot net
oder ein future in javascript also das ist quasi ein platzhalter für einen wert der
in zukunft verfügbar sein wird versteht man was ich meine also dieser server ist zu dem
zeitpunkt nicht angelegt aber ich kann trotzdem schon auf die eigenschaften des servers zugreifen
so als wären sie angelegt also das ist ja an der stelle nicht erzeugt aber ich kann
sagen wenn der server erzeugt ist an der stelle dann möchte ich mit dem wert sobald da bereit
steht folgendes machen nämlich mir die netzwerk ip rausholen also unter der haube ist es
eigentlich ganz einfach unter der haube ist es ganz einfach ich sage hier ich will den
server anlegen und das hier wartet einfach so lange bis der server angelegt wurde und
eine ip bekommen hat übers dhcp ich glaube jetzt hat man es verstanden oder das hier
gibt das hier macht die anfrage legt den server an der server wird angelegt das dauert dann
20 30 sekunden und nach diesen 20 30 sekunden wenn der server aufgebaut ist und bei dhcp
eine adresse gekriegt hat dann wird das hier ausgeführt so lange wartet das dann wird
der rest ausgeführt das heißt so kriege ich die server ip raus und das will ich jetzt
mal ausbrühen ob das überhaupt funktioniert was ich hier mache deswegen geben wir machen
wir einfach mal console console right line irgendwie IP und gucken ob das funktioniert
was ich mir jetzt hier ausgedacht habe die turn meinetwegen auch wann beginnt mein neuer
job am 1.4. und heute passend zu weihnachten wir gucken jetzt mal ob das hier stimmt was
ich gebaut habe und heute passend zu weihnachten kam die zusage dass auch der betriebsrat zugestimmt
hat das war klar das war quasi das letzte was hätte noch einen strich durch die rechnung
machen können ich habe schon den vertrag auch schon unterschrieben und alles gut aber
das war nur noch vorbehaltlich mit der bis zur zustimmung des betriebsrat heute habe
ich den brief gekriegt betriebsrat hat zugestimmt also alles gut das heißt die sache ist jetzt
rechts kräftig aber erst zum 4.9.job und nächste woche dienstag gebe ich meine kündigung ab
oder mittwoch gehalt gehalt ist finde ich relativ gut ja also ich verdiene quasi mit
dem neuen gehalt also hätte ich beim alten job fünf tage die woche gearbeitet wäre das
immer noch einen ticken weniger gewesen als beim neuen job mit vier tagen also hat sich
schon hat sich schon ein bisschen was getan also sind ungefähr 105 und ungefähr 105
k ich habe es vorhin am anfang des streams mal relativ genau erklärt weil es der chat
natürlich wieder wissen wollte sind ungefähr 105 k mit ein bisschen bonus mit ein bisschen
mehr und ein bisschen weniger tendenziell wahrscheinlich mit dem boom eher ein ticken
mehr aber im prinzip in der richtung ja es finde ich sehr nice in welcher branche ich
bleibe in der frankfurter finanz branche ich bin jetzt bei einer bank und ich wechsel dann
quasi zu einer versicherung oder zu einer versicherung stonks das hatte aber auch gefallen
dass ich in mein in mein skill oder in mein lebenslauf oder irgendwo hat ich es reingeschrieben 15
jahre finanz branche erfahrung oder sowas ok wir lassen das jetzt mal applyn und gucken ob das
mit dem mit dem erkennender ip adresse funktioniert also was ich vor habe ist folgendes ich möchte
hier zwei server anlegen und dann möchte ich die ip adresse dieser server mir speichern und wenn
ich meinen monitoring server der diese anderen server dann überwachen soll erstelle möchte
ich gleich dem die ip adressen der server die er überwachen soll mitgeben 4000 euro gaming
ich habe 5000 euro gaming pc gebaut was macht man eigentlich mit der ganzen kole ehrlich gesagt
ich werde mit der kole das gleiche machen was ich vorher mit der kole auch gemacht habe sie
nicht ausgeben weil ich habe euch ja schon oft gesagt das beste ist um immer mehr um
immer genug geld zu haben einfach weniger geld ausgeben als man bekommt
irgendwas ist kaputt leute invalid value for field resource name back end keck we must be a match
of regex ja alles klar ich erkenne jetzt instant was der regex mir sagen soll ich glaube der regex
soll mir sagen ich darf keck wenig groß schreiben kann das sein warum ist der error bitte schön
nicht cannot contain uppercase letters oder sowas sondern so ein blöder regex man 105k netto oder
protoprot nicht netto netto wäre ein bisschen übertrieben also ich muss da drauf noch steuern
bezahlen ok dann nennen wir keck weh nennen wir einfach klein keck keck w create yes das gibt es
ja noch hätte man mit das gibt es ja gerade mal mit ach und krach vielleicht in der schweiz oder
noch nicht mal wahrscheinlich ich kann jetzt quasi allen subs gif genau logik das ist glaube ich
die beste art und weise mein geld auszugeben ich mache quasi eine indirekte überweisung an besos
richtig stonks ja weiterhin vier arbeiten vier tage die woche ja korrekt auch immer es hat
funktioniert hey leute es klappt guck mal ich bekomme die ip ich bekomme die ip von der kiste
nice das ist gut ich bekomme die ip von den kisten die aufgebaut wurde lasst uns mal überprüfen ob
die ip von den kisten auch stimmt ja 2 4 und 3 ist das monitoring system excellent so und jetzt
ist die große preisfrage ich habe die ip ist hier wie bekomme ich die ip adressen jetzt in
die config von meinem monitoring server was willst du angel investor für ideen aus dem chat es
kommt auf die gut jetzt kommt auf die ideen an vom chat wenn die ideen so mega krass sind dass
ich davon super überzeugt bin dann ist sag ich nicht nein ja das muss schon eine richtig krasse
idee sein irgendwas was mich direkt belieben lässt ja aber ist alles kein problem ist alles
kein problem wenn man das passende alpha kranzett mindset hat kennt ihr das alpha kranzett mindset
wenn ihr es nicht kennt müsst ihr unbedingt in die whatsapp gruppe kommen da erklären die
euch das wie das funktioniert ist wohl ein trend den chat seine arbeit machen zu lassen wenn es
mal funktioniert würde wobei funktioniert ja der chat hat glaube ich noch nie was falsches gesagt
oder könnt ihr könnt ihr euch könnt ihr euch an einen fall erinnern wo der chat mal was falsches
gesagt hat das kann eigentlich nicht sein also gestimmt stimmt schon ja chat gpt hat zu fragen
mit dem halt kannst du zweimal preisschamp selber hausen das ist richtig das problem am
preisschamp waren aber nicht die haus den gebühren sondern dass ich keinen bock hatte den crawler
aktuell zu halten verleiht den chain nur nicht blödsinn zu posten das geht oftmals in die hose
ja so ist das giga gig nur giga chat chats mit t hier hinten ok weiter im text also das
hat funktioniert ich bekomme die ip ist von den was das was patrick was war was sollte das
gewesen sein war das was schlimmes ich erkenne es nicht vielleicht sollte ich es auch besser
nicht erkennt man muss früh anfangen du hast recht du hast recht sonst denkt er wieder er kann
in den kurbischen subreddits posten da weißt du nie das war ein christmas tree sollte denn ich
eigentlich mehrzeitig sein verkackt chat gpt ist das was ziemlich gut auf auf deine ja auf
deine fragen antworten kann beziehungsweise natürlich nicht gut ziemlich gut natürlich
dass das wort war ich weiß mir grad natürlich auf deine frage antworten kann so jetzt ist die
preisfrage wie bekomme ich die sehr gut chain law excellent excellent endlich endlich mal was
gescheites aber hier erkennt man das nicht wirklich erkenne ich den erkenne ich den baum bei mir in
der vorschau warte mal in der vorschau sieht er baum baumiger aus auf jeden fall im fullscreen
geht es halt nicht ok so jetzt machen wir mal weiter jetzt ist die große also ich versuche
es noch mal zu recapen wir bauen zwei backend server auf und ich möchte jetzt ein monitoring
server erstellen der in seiner konfiguration schon diese zwei server die überwachen soll eingetragen
hat das heißt wie kriege ich die ip adresse von da jetzt sagen wir mal in das start script rein
also sagen wir mal so was wie echo ip 1 und echo ip 2 in da rein so wie bekomme ich hier in
diese start script die ip adressen wie soll ich das jetzt machen gescheit weil das hier läuft ja
eventuell erst nachdem dieser server schon angelegt wurde ok leute ich habe ich habe
ein polumi tutorial gelesen letztens back end ip new list output sekunde was ist das für
ein typ hier kackel was ist das für ein typ hier output string direkt ok das ist easy string ok
back end ip kann ich sowas hier machen ads ich glaube das funktioniert ok alles klar jetzt
habe ich eine liste mit allen ip's meiner back end server und die muss ich jetzt in mein start
script rein kriegen alter das ist ja six hat wie soll das funktionieren kann ich kann ich
einfach sagen string interpolation und wir schreiben wieder jetzt rein oder geht das jetzt
kann ich jetzt einfach sowas sagen hier wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich wird das nicht gehen
back end ip's nehmen wir mal die erste die erste ip da raus und sagen ach du scheiße
wie soll das jetzt funktionieren wie soll ich hier den text rein kriegen man
ne so funktioniert das nicht wie kriege ich an die stelle jetzt die ip also das hier ist
jetzt stellvertretend für beispielsweise prometors jammel oder so wie wie kriege ich wie kriege ich
die back end ip's jetzt da rein so schon mal nett to string keine ahnung ich versuchte es
jetzt mal auszuführen dann gucken was passiert echo das da gequoted natürlich noch und jetzt
nach test das funktioniert im leben nicht das wäre auch ziemlich pervers fast schon das so
zu machen aber bin ich mal gespannt ob das klappt ok ok ok ok bin ich mal sehr bin ich mal sehr
gespannt ob das funktioniert ich ich predicte ja mal dass es nicht funktioniert weil an sich ist
es ja von der idee schon recht nice wenn ich hier die ip's habe alle back end server und ich
gleichzeitig ein monitoring system erstellen kann was direkt beim erstellen alle back end
ip's diese überwachen soll mitbekommt muss ich überhaupt nichts mehr von hand nichts mehr von
hand konfigurieren ich habe ein polumi tutorial gelesen und zwar polumi output input string
interpolation da stand so was in der richtung drinne wie das funktioniert ja viel spaß
interpolation brauchen wir jetzt working with outputs and strings would like to produce a string ja
genau so was will ich haben output format hostname port ja genau so was in der richtung will ich
tatsächlich haben bin mal gespannt ob das funktioniert hast du das ausgerechnet nice quick
sehr gut aber ich will gar nicht in thailand oder in vietnam oder so in rente gehen
so schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert hat ich habe ja da meine zweifel ehrlich gesagt
refreschen wir das ganze mal hier verbinden uns per ssh drauf und gucke mal ob das funktioniert
hat ich beliebe ja noch nicht so richtig die musik fertig auf google cloud sei mal nicht so
langsam ok also slash test punkt txt kaputt ist es calling to string 20 output ist noch
supportet was auch immer für eine scheiß fehlermeldung mann ok das dachte ich mir dass
das nicht so einfach funktionieren kann es wäre jetzt auch zu easy gewesen ok wie kriege ich die
ip mann das ist ja viel komplizierter als ich gedacht habe wie kriege ich die ip von hier darein
ach du scheiße wie geht das
das bin ich echt
to string ne to string wird automatisch aufgerufen an der stelle hat gesagt das darf ich nicht
aufrufen weil to string nicht nicht erlaubt ist was für einen typ back end ip
sind eine list von output string output ist von polumi das was quasi in task oder in future
in javascript ist ein wert der eventuell mal zur verfügung stehen wird deswegen kannst du
auch nicht direkt to string darauf ausrufen darauf aufrufen weil es ja zu dem zeitpunkt
eventuell noch gar nicht da ist da gibt es wie gesagt ich habe ich habe mir das tutorial
durchgelesen mann kann ihn quasi sagen er soll warten darauf bis es dann da ist so in dieser
richtung hier all da fack mann wie funktioniert das format so hier so in dieser richtung müsste
das eigentlich funktionieren also output format sagen wir jetzt einfach mal hier ip nennen
das mal nur ip output format wie sieht so ein prometoids eintritt aus prometoids konfig wie
sieht so eine minimale prometoids konfig aus die setzt auch die ist doch relativ das ist
keine minimale prometoids konfig getting started so was genauso ein teil brauche ich ok start
script das schreibe ich jetzt nicht in line rein machen wir hier konfig gleich string
literals weil bestes feature was sie seit langem eingeführt haben so das meine prometoids
konfig das ist jetzt schon wieder so viel wo ich sagen würde da würde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht in line schreiben scrape intervall label keck keck weh string interpolation name monitor
ja bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla alles weg bis übersichtlicher wird das brauchen
wir nicht überschreiben so targets das ist das hier muss hier muss die ip rein hier muss
hier muss die ip an der stelle rein also sprich ip output format wir wollen jetzt die ip in
diesem format da reinschreiben mit oder muss ich jetzt vielleicht diesen format muss das
da rein also machen wir mal so und an der stelle muss nicht localhost hin sondern testweise
mal nur die erste backend ips first so haben wir die prometoids konfig die prometoids konfig
kriegt an der stelle die ip rein nicht wirklich die ip ist ja im prinzip target targets muss
das heißen und die prometoids konfig kommt dann abschließend hier in das startup script
also ob das ob das funktioniert keck weight wo muss denn wo muss denn das hin ja das kann
man ruhig in txt na ob das jetzt so klappt da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das tut so sagt
mir präge leute chat präge präge passt heute doppelt es wird einmal geprayt für weihnachten
und es wird geprayt dass meine polumi konfig funktioniert das finde ich gut compile and
pray das ist natürlich bei der hetsner cloud deutlich angenehmer da ist so vms erstellen
und löschen mega schnell versus google vms dort ist es eine sache von ein paar sekunden
und hier watzte teilweise eine minute bis der campel durch ist so was wir übrigens im hintergrund
schön sieht ist dass der hier gerade gar nichts macht ach doch ach ja was hier auch polumi
ist feifert an der stelle guck mal der legt eine neue vm an als replacement für die alte
und erst wenn die neue oben ist und professioniert ist löscht er die alte das ist eigentlich
relativ clever da hat man minimale down time o weihnachten mark seit dem dual kommentar
mit frisörn kaboom am start der lumpenmeckes der name sagt mir auch noch was kommt mir
bekannt vor habe ich ich habe dich glaube ich schon auf youtube gereden der lumpenmeckes
schön dass du dir hier den weg her gefunden hast dankeschön auch für den prime sub und
sorry an alle die ich vielleicht übersehen habe glaube nicht dass ich einen übersehen
habe aber kann schon sein so polumi stellt bist du fertig hast es geschafft google warum
bist du so lahm wir gucken mal wie mein aktuelles video läuft lass mal kurz ab check so an ein
browser schläft ja fast einmal nur läuft gut in wirklichkeit sind wir wahrscheinlich
jetzt bei denk mal so 7000 views das aktualisiert er nicht richtig 6 7000 views denke ich sind
wir jetzt als polo das ist immer noch nicht fertig zwei minuten für das popelische anlegen
und löschen einer vm also das muss google mal irgendwie beschleunigen das kälte doch
nicht aus da drehst du doch durch bei wenn du da was ausprobieren willst immer zwei minuten
war okay fertig fertig alles klar und warum erstellt warum macht er die seite nicht automatisch
ab to date wie sieht das bei dir an der abend aus stirbt langsam teil eins plus also wenn
schon nur teil eins teil eins ist der beste nee ich gehe jetzt erstmal was richtig krass
pepo fett muttern um 18 o'clock ok prägen dass der kram jetzt funktioniert hat mit den
ip's also kett etc nicht etc slash test pack wie macht man das jetzt richtig aber ich
bin dazu dumm die ip reinzukriegen der rest sieht ja schon nach prometheus konfig aus
aber alter welcher super high IQ entwickler hat sich das dann ausgedacht google sagt man
muss bei output values mit apply was machen das hilft mir jetzt nicht wirklich außerdem
mache ich da oben ja schon was mit apply po wie
soll das jetzt funktionieren ok ich glaube ich glaube das problem ist nicht das hier
sondern dass ich das hier einsetze vielleicht ich glaube ich weiß was ich machen muss wartet
mal ich habe was gelesen in dem tutorial und zwar genau hier irgendwas mit all if you have
multiple also multiple outputs and you need to join them das ist das was ich machen muss
ich habe ja mehrere ip adressen die ich join will dann muss ich verwenden output all output
all ach du scheiße wie soll das jetzt funktionieren man output all so back end ip's apply so und
das apply läuft dann erst ok ich glaube ich glaube so funktioniert das das das apply läuft
dann erst einmalig wenn die server angelegt sind und es überhaupt per dhcp eine ip gibt
das heißt solange wartet das also apply oder keine ahnung ip's machen wir hier so was
so und dann machen wir das da rein jetzt wirds jetzt wirds auch richtig high IQ hier da rein
so dann brauche ich sowas wie targets hier auch wieder targets output format ne das brauche
ich ja an der stelle gar nicht hier brauche ich dann eigentlich gar nichts oder einfach
nur back end ne back end ip ist schon das was ich brauche ip's genau dann brauche ich nämlich
an der stelle string weil jetzt ist der wert ja da jetzt ist es ja kein output mehr sondern
direkt ein string array jetzt kann ich sagen output ne ich brauche schon sowas wie targets
aber ich brauche targets und jetzt und jetzt sowas wie ip's select und jetzt muss ich
das in das richtige format erstmal bringen boah das ist ja next level high IQ shit bis
man hier mal ip formatiert hat jetzt brauche ich im prinzip sowas also das ganze muss in
single anführungsstrichen dann kommt doppelt port doppelt punkt port 90 weil es ist glaube
ich oder 9100 und hiervon muss dann die ip wenn ich das jetzt richtig im kopf habe so
jetzt und jetzt muss ich sagen string join weil jetzt sind es ja wirklich echte werte
an der stelle string join targets monkaS man monkaW und das return was ich als start
up script so das was ich hier als output rauskriege will ich dann hier reinschreiben und es heißt
ich muss noch ein echo davor machen ach du große scheiße man also will ich quasi dann
sowas hier noch machen echo und dann prometheus konfig da beiß ich mir den arsch wenn das
jetzt funktioniert prometheus konfig und das ganze posten wir nach keinem test 1.txt
oder so pragen noch mal chat wir müssen noch mal eine runde pragen ob das jetzt funktioniert
das ist zumindest von der idee her schon mal richtiger als vorher weil hier warte ich bis
die werte zur verfügung stehen und machen dann erst weiter hoffentlich crash nicht direkt
beim ausführen auf geht's break it time yes jetzt dauert der mist wieder zwei minuten
weil google cloud so langsam ist ok wir gucken wir gucken einfach nicht hin wir gucken einfach
nicht hin wir machen wir tun einfach so als wird es funktionieren und machen weiter beziehungsweise
machen wir als nächstes also wenn das jetzt funktioniert dann habe ich eine datei wo eine
prometheus konfig drin steht aber ich habe noch gar kein prometheus installiert das
ist natürlich doof das bedeutet ich muss eine prometheus konfig anlegen nee ich muss
erst mal erst mal was ganz anderes machen als erstes muss ich ab update minus minus
yes machen so easy dann muss ich wie war das debian frontend oder sowas debian frontend
glücklicherweise hat mir das kommando letztens jemand geschickt im chat weil ich mir das
immer nicht merken kann da muss ich sagen upgrade yes dann haben wir die neuesten pakete wobei
brauche ich gar nicht ich brauche install ich brauche schon install braucht kein upgrade install
install prometheus wenn ich also richtig schreibe prometheus oder prometheus wie die amis das
nennen dann lege ich eine konfig an und zwar die konfig lege ich an und der etc prometheus
und dann heißt das ding glaube ich prometheus punkt jammel oder jammel wie wie heißt die datei
jammel oder jammel also jammel mit dem a oder ohne a jimmel jimmel ok jimmel
vorher sage ich noch system ctl stop prometheus und ich muss hinter alles noch ein semi kohle
und machen dass das funktioniert das ist ja nämlich alles eine zeile eigentlich und jetzt
habe ich das themen ctl start prometheus gut so weit so gut ok es ist fertig jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt mal gucken ob die ganze das ganze gepräge was geholfen hat schauen wir mal
keck wem und null ist am start ich habe noch 50 minuten zeit das irgendwie zum laufen zu
kriegen dann muss ich weihnachts hapa hapa machen weihnachts pippo fett ok
etc nicht etc mann test hey es funst targets ips jawoll nice wir haben eine prometheus konfig
wo alle automatisch vorher aufgebauten backend server automatisch eingetragen werden das ist
sehr cool da brauchen wir keinen discovery oder sonst was wie gesagt ich würde es live nicht so
bauen dann würde ich den monitoring server außerhalb dieser dieses dieser konfig bauen
was gibt es bei dir ich weiß nicht wie es heißt aber es sind hackfleisch bällchen mit soße und
viel baguette so ein bisschen was leichteres dass man nicht komplett voll gefressen aber ich
fresse mich trotzdem wieder bis ich mal rein passt rein passt voll also nice es hat funktioniert
wir haben die ip ist hier drinnen was mega nice ist weil wenn ich jetzt hier oben einfach
reinschreibe ich will acht server aufbauen dann hat auf einmal mein monitoring direkt die acht
server drin das ist das ist mega nice ist natürlich nicht für historische daten weil
der monitoring server immer neu erstellt wird wenn sich da dran was ändert also für historische
daten ist es nix deswegen würde ich so wahrscheinlich auch live direkt nicht betreiben ok nice nice nice
nice hat jetzt eigentlich auch prometheus installiert muss ich mal gucken das habe ich
noch gerade ausgeführt was muss ich was polumi export leute passwort liegt nicht weiter verraten
ok ich erwarte von euch dass ihr bei sowas immer die augen zu macht wenn ich passwörter
liege liege best best practice passwort wieder yes ok also wenn das jetzt funktioniert wäre
extrem progas dann hätte ich ein monitoring system installiert mit prometheus drauf der
die server versucht schon abzufragen ok das heißt ich muss meine firewall übrigens auch
noch erweitern nämlich um port 9001 weil der nodex port auf 9100 9100
kannst wieder schauen ich habe es ausgeblendet und hier ist er immer noch zu sehen immer noch
immer noch liegt demnächst alle stream nur noch mit mit augenbinde doch doch du kannst
mit verschlossen augen stream schauen du machst den stream an und machst die augen zu das zählt
als viewer ob du wirklich zuschaust ist egal ihr habt die augen zu hören bin ich ja froh
kann ich alles liegen ist google cloud teilweise langsam so also ich gehe jetzt einfach ich
gehe jetzt einfach mal von aus dass es dass es funktioniert das heißt wir müssen auf
unseren anderen system auch noch prometheus installieren das darf man ja nicht vergessen
das das fehlt ja noch also mache ich da auch mal das gleiche update minus minus yes und
dann sage ich debian frontend non interactive was auch immer install prometheus nodexporter
install prometheus minus ich glaube so heißt das nodexporter und dann brauche ich ein restart
ich glaube nicht habe ich beim install das minus minus yes hier unten vergessen das
ist schon mal blöd da muss auf jeden fall noch jetzt hinten dran weil sonst hängt es
eventuell ok nice kennst du dich mit browser hijack aus habe gestern in einem stream gesehen
wie einem 60k gescannt wurden würde mich mal interessieren wie so etwas passieren
kann es kommt ein bisschen drauf an was da was man da jetzt gesehen hat was da was da
passiert ist also um da was hijacken zu können muss es ja erst mal irgendwelche sessions
klauen also letztendlich irgendwelche cookies klauen das kann sie nicht so einfach ist das
hier fertig aus ist fertig alles klar guck mal jetzt ging es auch schneller ne ich habe
doch gar nichts gemacht alles alles gut also und die aktivisten prometheus nodexporter
prometheus und export hier ok das heißt jetzt bekomme ich jetzt müsste es jetzt müsste es
doch funktionieren eigentlich schon ok ich bin gespannt ich bin gespannt danach können
wir es ordentlich machen noch die letzten 40 50 minuten ok wir bekommen zwei backends
bekommen monitoring server der monitoring server registriert sich automatisch jedes
backend was aufgebaut wurde und fragt es ab das heißt wir können uns schon mal ein lokalen
skaffana starten ja wunderbar und wir brauchen einen google cloud tunnel dass das funktioniert
das habe ich mir im vorfeld schon aufgeschrieben wie man das macht weil das weiß wirklich aus
dem kopf niemand wo habe ich es denn hier ja hier ist es soll wir brauchen was das hier
ober restart docker restart im zweifelsfall wenn es irgendwelche probleme hat was ist
das problem ich habe körner update gemacht deswegen geht das shit nicht ok ich muss meine
muss meine kiste neu starten aber mal trotzdem kurz also google compute start iap tunnel
so und zwar wir wollen uns tunnen zu erst mal warten bis es hier alles durch ist wir
wollen uns tunnen zu irgendwie kw service oder so hier mon dahin wollen wir uns tunnen
port 9100 localhost port mip meine güde high q command ist das jetzt support lokal 9100
wunderbar ok das sollte jetzt eigentlich funktionieren hast du ahnung von sinkpads ich weiß dass
das ehemalig also lenovo notebook sind ehemalig ibm aber ansonsten kann ich dir auch nicht
mehr sagen wie jeder andere auf jetzt google cloud machen wir hinne alter kann doch nicht
sein dass es immer 50 stunden braucht um zwei vms zu erzeugen macarist würde ich auch nicht
machen fack facebook der hat irgendwas mit den cookies gezeigt ja das kann sein klar
ich meine es doch logisch kommt mal ihr habt irgendwelche sessions mit einer webseite und
jemand klaut alle eure cookies beziehungsweise alle eure sessions und dann kann er natürlich
eure session auch übernehmen aber du kannst normalerweise nicht so einfach die cookies
klauen da brauchst du schon irgendwas auf dem rechner drauf irgendein trojaner oder
irgendwelche bösen hacking tools nur durch das zeigen also das geht wahrscheinlich schon
dann müsste aber irgendwie dann müsstest du den kompletten inhalt des cookies zeigen
der cookies wahrscheinlich reicht da eins nicht im stream jemand müsste das abtippen
und dass du da alles auf einmal liegst ist recht unwahrscheinlich da müsste jemand die
browser dev tools aufmachen die cookies der seite durchklicken das ist eher unwahrscheinlich
also und dann irgendjemand müsste es abtippen ok fertig zeigt mal ja ok jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das funktioniert hat also wir machen application server auf und wir machen
den monitoring server auf auf dem application server sollte ein prometheus laufen und auf
dem monitoring service hier sollten prometheus nodexporter laufen und hier sollte ein prometheus
laufen der das alles einsammelt ok schau mal etc test prometheus ist noch nicht installiert
kann das sein alles hat nicht funktioniert warum was ist an meinem high iq was ist an
meinem an meinem script falsch leute abt update da kann ja ich komme nicht ins internet das
ist das problem ich denke wir müssen ja doch natt einrichten ich komme ja gar nicht ins
internet die können ja nichts installieren guck mal der kann überhaupt nicht installieren
die kiste das ist kein wunder dass das installieren nicht funktioniert ok wie wie richte ich
natt ein das habe ich mir auch schon im vorfeld angeguckt ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schwierig
wie man wie man glauben mag das kann ich mir wohin das habe ich das habe ich mir schon
angeguckt im vorfeld war ich denn netwerk hier also netwerk set up netwerk set up firewall
gcp netwerk firewall wo ist es router exakt das da guck mal das habe ich schon mal vorbereitet
man muss folgendes noch machen das da zone was ist die zone ja zone was ist denn die
zone europe europe west oder europe west ok das muss man machen und zwar man legt netzwerk
an firewall an dann legt man einen router an und dann legt man darauf eine natt regel
an und sagt ihm hey sucht ja automatisch natt ips raus für alle systeme die ins internet
wollen konfiguration wir es fack aber so funktioniert das das habe ich mir gestern schon angeguckt
das müssen wir jetzt hier nicht ich muss jetzt nicht im stream so tun so nach dem motto
wie geht das denn ein router anlegen ich weiß schon ich weiß schon wie es funktioniert
was ist denn mit dem thinkpad jetzt gewesen moment bevor ich mir das angucke bevor ich
den chat angucke lege ich das hier an weil google cloud braucht wahrscheinlich wieder
eine ganze weile und eine wichtige sache habe ich auch noch vergessen damit ich ping testen
kann brauche ich das hier noch zusätzlich sag uns und 90 90 machen wir auch noch kann
nämlich sein dass es ok gut auf gehts anlegen und dann komm ich den chat auf also was will
er anlegen neue router neue natt regeln und die firewall update yes excellent failed
warum was ist denn failed network id invalid value for field region unknown region ok was
ist was ist verkehrt ach so es ist nur europe west ich bin blöd es ist es ist ok das ist
die zone ich muss ja die region angeben für das netzwerk das ist nur europe west 3 wir
löschen es noch mal und dann lasse ich es neu anlegen alles klar also chat was war jetzt
mit den sing so hell mit den singpads er wollte er will sie ein singpad zulegen für ein bisschen
die los die lindungsdinger sind gar nicht übel mit singpads zumindest war sie das in
der vergangenheit immer und weiter warum machst du es nicht ach so ja das kann ich dir auch
nicht sagen du kannst von ausgehen dass die singpads in der regel meist also alle singpads
die ich bisher hatte und ich hatte auf der arbeit eigentlich so gut wie immer singpads
außer jetzt habe ich ein surface book und surface tablet oder sowas surface surface book
top surface book heißt die liefen alle wunderbar mit linux also ich mache ich lege cloud ressourcen
an per config management oder per infrastructure as code tool wie sich das natürlich viel
besser anhört ja wünschen wir dir auch alle ich spreche jetzt einfach mal für den chat
zusammen ich bin eine halbe stunde bin ich noch da und ich hoffe dass ich den graben
bis dahin hinkriege als wir das nächste mal eine spannende machen können nämlich lautbalancer
je nach regionen die requests balancen lassen und sowas auf dem singpad willst du ein altes
mmo laufen lassen also die on-board gpu sind meistens ziemlich erschrocken aber für alte
mmos tut ja fast alles google cloud please mach hin wie kann man so langsam sein ich
verstehe das nicht was machen die denn da machen die beim fiverr in der den auftrag
dass der in ihr rechenzentrum in was auch immer in das indische rechenzentrum ist läuft
warum ist das denn so langsam warum brauchst du zum löschen einer vm über zwei minuten
google hetzer macht das in drei sekunden gut die google cloud kann auch mehr aber das interessiert
mich in dem fall jetzt nicht keine ahnung ob das so langsam ist es auf jeden fall abfangen
oh leute ich brauche noch weihnachtsgeschenke sollen wir mal warmer zonen gucken okay ich
gebe zu zwar ein schlechter witz aber ich habe wirklich nicht so viel dieses jahr best
seller in books meine güter mann google google mach hinne amazon fliegt mit drohne zu dir
nach hause amazon hat same day delivery leider im prinzip ist das einen halben kilometer
im nachbarort endet das bis zu mir geht es nicht aber ist jetzt nicht so schlimm vielleicht
geht es auch mittlerweile
bei der way ich glaube 90 90 ist sogar der richtige port 90 90 ist nämlich der prometheus
aber selbst hat es geschafft ok jetzt kann ich den kram anlegen ich hoffe das geht jetzt
ein bisschen schneller und wenn das fertig ist haben wir wahrscheinlich neu starten dass
die kritische stocker grafana starten kann weil das geht ja dann können update nicht
halbe stunde bin ich noch da gibt es noch irgendwelche spannende neuen themen wo wir
drüber reden müssen wo ich nichts zu gesagt habe gibt es irgendwas spannendes also falls
ihr nicht gesehen habt ich habe heute auch ein video hochgeladen also wer das noch nicht
gesehen hat kann er mal einen blick rein werfen ich bin jetzt übrigens nicht nur max fps
ich bin sogar et max fps warum auch immer aber es funktioniert jetzt wie findet ihr
eigentlich die letzten paar thumbnails wie findet ihr das das das das das also ihr seht
hier so ein bisschen meinen alten thumbnail style und den neuen die neuen mache ich nicht
mehr selbst die alten habe ich die alten habe ich selbst gemacht wird ihr eigentlich gar
nicht übel
wie funktioniert denn grob ein load balancer der je nach region das requests die anfragen
gutet also du meinst jetzt wenn man den selbst bauen würde was man dafür braucht weil wenn
du nämlich den fertig google load balancer verwendest ist es easy da macht das einfach
für dich aber kann ich gleich was zu sagen ich will nur mal kurz checken ob das ob das
jetzt alles funktioniert hat hallo ok ah die gibt es nicht mehr moment ich muss refreshen
sag ich gleich was zu so ist ja gut alle gehen mal weg mal gucken ob ich hier eine verbindung
aufbauen kann zu der kiste was you've already logged in with a different ich kann euch ok
das kann ich jetzt nicht machen da muss ich passwort und so klartext eingeben wahrscheinlich
egal ob das hier funktioniert hat
google please so ist jetzt ein prometo ist drauf jawoll sehr schön und läuft er auch
system ctl status prometoys der läuft auch exzellent so kat etc prometoys prometoys jammel
und hat als targets auch die ganzen server konfiguriert mal gucken ob die verbindung
zwischen den servoren tut 10 5 6 0.3 wunderbar das funktioniert auch ja web mit grafana kann
ich jetzt leider nicht connecten oder wobei warum kann ich nicht geklaut konfig set account
das war jetzt blöd oder jetzt wird es auch nicht funktionieren in set account wirklich
ich lasse alles zu exzellent willkommen bei google cloud tunnel jawoll tunnel funktioniert
ok moment mal gucken karl local host 90 90 ne ip add nice ok der prometoys läuft jetzt
müsste ich nur noch mein lokales grafana zum laufen kriegen dazu dazu muss ich rebooten
weil ich habe kein update gemacht
wie viel zahlen wir für ein thumbnail ist nicht viel nicht viel also ich habe ich habe
dem letzten 50 euro überwiesen für die nächsten paar thumbnails der wird mir dann glaube
ich sagen wenn es geld aufgebraucht ist
google cloud perfekt ok jetzt nochmal kurz das ganze checken docker run grafana wunderbar
ja tunnel ja ok karl exzellent exzellent ok also jetzt nochmal kurz checken ob das alles
funktioniert ich glaube admin admin ist es standardmäßig jawoll admin ja genau das
wollte ich schon immer machen was achso ja ja ganz toll so jetzt haben wir hier unser
lokales grafana also ich habe jetzt ein tunnel gemacht google cloud things tunnel auf meinen
monitoring server ich benutze arch by the way ja jetzt führen wir den graf mal hinzu
data sources prometoys ok local aus 1990 ok ach ne es ist ja nicht local aus was warum
wo ist das problem ok alles klar hatte tp da vorschreiben dann dann gut
explore loading matrix nice funktioniert also nur mal so um das jetzt um das jetzt zusammen
zu passen gucken wir mal hier keine ahnung memory usage oder so
notes memory free oder wie heißt der kram free used wie heißt das noch mal memory mem
free balz genau
aber ändert prometoys wieder laufen sei oberfläche oder warum sieht es auf einmal so verkackt aus
halt ist auch nicht mem free es ist ne was war es denn jetzt memory mem free balz genau
und wir können unsere server überwachen also nur mal so was das was wo man wirklich
sieht wie praktisch diese tools sind also ich habe jetzt mit also ich muss meine idee
wieder aufmachen was überhaupt das richtige projekt ich hoffe mal ja genau also ich habe
jetzt ein netzwerk angelegt in der google cloud und zwar ein netzwerk was hallo möchte
klicken please ok meine editor ist noch nicht gestartet jetzt soll ich lege google cloud
netzwerk an und zwar netzwerk was internal heißt mit einer firewall für eingehende
verbindung als cmp ist erlaubt tcp ist erlaubt auf 80 22 90 90 und 9100 dann lege ich einen
router an und eine natt regel dass die ganzen server die ich anlege und an dieses netzwerk
attacke ins internet dürfen mit einer extern ip dann lege ich zwei backend server an jeweils
mit ubuntu drauf installiert drauf ein prometors nodex nodex porter ich speichere mir die ips
dieser angelegten vms erzeuge eine monitoring vm die automatisch eine config bekommt mit
den ips der backend server und dann automatisch die server überwacht natürlich ohne regel
und sonst was aber das ist eigentlich eine coole sache weil zum beispiel wenn ich jetzt
sagen würde ok mir reichen vier server nicht mehr dann trage ich da oder drei oder trage
ich hier acht ein und ich führe das aus und habe ich auf einmal acht server ohne dass
ich was ändern muss mit dem gleichen setup und dass es funktioniert sieht man hier weil
hier kriege ich live jetzt die daten im grafana von meinen zwei backend server und zwar in
dem fall hier die memory usage dann sieht man aus irgendwelchen gründen haben die unterschiedliche
memory usage aber das ist ja auch hier auf beid also im prinzip liegen die auch bloß
irgendwie 2mb oder so auseinander das halt mega nice jetzt könnte ich sagen ach nö weißt
du was ich ich hätte ich hätte gern lieber acht backend server und dann machen wir das
hier mal aus grafana kommen auch aus machen ist auch egal da gehe ich hier hin und sag
ja nee ein bisschen bisschen bisschen wenig backend server ich ich will lieber acht backend
server haben dann führe ich das aus und er sagt aha aha damit du acht backend server
kriegst muss ich folgendes machen nämlich sieben neue erstellen weil ein hast du ja
schon yes und ihr werdet sehen sobald er anfängt zu laufen hier er erstellt neue backend server
und er erstellt ein neues monitorsystem weil sich die config ja geändert hat weil in der
config automatisch alle backend server eingetragen werden das heißt ich warte jetzt drei minuten
ich habe meine neue umgebung fix und fertig dastehen ohne dass ich was machen muss das
einzige was ich gemacht habe ist hier oben den die anzahl geändert das soll schon nice
und das ist noch relativ übersichtlich ja von der von der config weil wir machen es
dann auch das nächste mal noch ein bisschen schöner ich glaube 20 minuten schaffe ich
das jetzt nicht mehr aber irgendjemand wollte doch wissen wie load balancer funktioniert
da kann ich was zu sagen wie ein load balancer funktioniert er das nach request nach anfragen
routet also gibt es zwei zwei paar sachen dafür wir kümmern uns erst mal um das reine
load balancing da brauchst du ein load balancer der oder beziehungsweise eine software die
anfragen aufgrund der herkunfts ip weiter schicken kann da gibt es software für mit
näher mit einer mit einer ip datenbank die können die gucken danach wo kommt die wo kommt
das her und kann es dann dementsprechend weiter schicken oder was auch machen kannst es kannst
es auch bei dns machen du kannst auch beispielsweise die die backends unterschiedlich auflösen
kannst zum beispiel sagen ok du hast dns service und der löst wenn anfragen aus den usa kommen
das zum backendservice für die usa auf und du hast anfragen wenn die aus der eu kommen
der löst es zum backendservice aus der eu auf in beiden fällen brauchst du irgendwie
ein stück software was checkt also mit irgendeiner datenbank wo die ips herkommen der weitere
punkt ist wenn du es richtig machen willst brauchst du noch sowas ne was heißt richtig
ne nicht wirklich aber wenn man es richtig richtig performant machen will dann brauchst
du noch sowas wie anycast und das ist auch das was unter der haube die google load balancer
benutzen damit das alles ordentlich performant läuft mit anycast kannst du eine ip haben
die es mehrfach auf der welt gibt normalerweise denkt man ja jede ip darf es nur einmal auf
der welt geben zumindest das was man so pauschal auch netzwerk technisch auch in der berufsschule
lernt also du kannst eigentlich eine ip in einem netzwerk nur einmal haben und im internet
könnte man dann so weit gehen und sagen ok du kannst eigentlich jede ip nur einmal haben
weil naja woher soll denn sonst der anfragende wissen wo es hin soll was ist mit ab das hat
auf der ebene erstmal nicht so das ist wenn du lokal meck ab ip zu meck adressen auflösen
musst in dem fall musst du auf jeden fall aus seinem lokalen netzwerk raus und zum router
da machst du dein ab request aber dann später musst du dir erstmal keine gedanken machen
es ist aber so mit anycast kannst du eine ip mehrfach auf der welt haben weil zum beispiel
den kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle oder den google dns meint ihr den google dns gibt es
wirklich genau einmal auf der welt gibt es natürlich nicht so den google dns gibt es
mehrfach auf der welt gibt es beispielsweise in den usa ostküste westküste westeuropa
central europa asien gibt es mehrfach auf der welt und die routen sind allerdings so
feifertig gemacht dass immer das zum nächst gelegenen geschickt wird also gibt es auch
einen da gibt es auch einen eintrag bei wikipedia zu wie das funktioniert beziehungsweise was
die vorteile sind sonst was damit kannst du dann quasi wenn die routen richtig also die
bgp routen und alles richtig konfiguriert also richtig announced wird dann geht es weil
bei routen zählt ja in der regel der schnellste weg oder der billigste weg der meistens auch
der schnellste und kürzeste weg ist das heißt dann hat schlicht und ergreifend die route
die dich die uns zum google dns in frankfurt führt höhere priorität als die route die
uns zum google dns an us westküste führt das heißt du kannst die gleiche ip sogar mehrfach
auf der welt haben und benutzt immer die kürzeste route das heißt du landest immer bei der
gleichen ip aber eigentlich sind es mehrere server auf der welt die diese ip haben aber
landest immer beim nächsten deswegen haben wir ja auch zum google dns plus ein ping von
zehn millisekunden oder sowas 19 18 schwankt immer ein bisschen wenn wir in die usa gehen
müssten hätten wir das gar nicht wenn du das dann kombinierst mit einem laut balancer
den es mehrfach auf der welt gibt so wie das der google google balancer macht und anhand
der quell ip dann auch noch feststellen kann an welches back end das ganze geschickt werden
soll ist natürlich wunderbar mit anycast ist es sogar noch einfacher weil der jeweilige
laut balancer am standort x auch nur die backends an standort x kennen muss also per anycast
sorgt dafür dass die anfragen aus den usa durch das routing auch an den laut balancer
in den usa gehen und der laut balancer in den usa der als back end hat einfach nur die
server in den usa konfiguriert also machst du eine anycast ip und das laut balancer
hinter dieser anycast ip balancer halt auf den jeweiligen standort da muss die anderen
gar nicht können also das ist die schöne variante kannst du natürlich auch anders
machen du kannst es per dns machen dns funktioniert auch dass du dir dass du eben je nach anfrage
also je nach region der anfrage gibt es sogar es gibt sogar ein open source projekt dns
haben wir sogar im stream schon mal verwendet was glaubt das ja gibt es ein paar projekte
auf github also kannst du bspw in dns server verwenden so geplendet hier gerade du kannst
zum beispiel in dns server verwenden der hat intern so eine geodatenbank also der erkennt
von welchem aus welcher region die absender ip der anfrage stammt und kann es dann unterschiedlich
auflösen also ich kann dann zum beispiel sagen aha das ist eine dns anfrage die kommt
aus den usa dann sage ich du musst eigentlich auf auf diese ip und wenn eine anfrage kommt
aus europa da kann ich sagen ah nee du musst jetzt dahin das ist auch eine möglichkeit
also kannst du das per anycast machen und dann direkt laut balancer oder du kannst es
beispielsweise auch über den dns server machen dass es unterschiedlich auflöst je nachdem
von wo du deinen service anfragst die dns variante ist wenn man es selber bauen will
die deutlich deutlich einfachere variante weil da musst du dich nicht mit bgp routing
und sachen auseinandersetzen was du auch als normalsterblicher im internet auch gar nicht
kannst du bist ja kein provider also bist du bist auf irgendeinen anbieter also wenn
du es mit anycast machen willst bist du auf irgendeinen anbieter angewiesen wenn du es
wirklich komplett selbst machen willst die einfachste variante ist tatsächlich das mit
einem dns zu machen du machst dns stellst du irgendwo hin der ist dann natürlich ursprünglich
langsam wenn einer aus asien anfragt aber who cares nach einer auflösung ist das ganze
ja gecasht stellst du dns hin in frankfurt mit sowas mit beispielsweise im geo dns drauf
und dann kommt eine anfrage aus asien und der dns sagt du kommst aus asien ich löse
jetzt dich zum backend service in asien auf und kriegst du eine ip von einem backend service
in asien wenn du aus europa kommst kriegst die ip von einem backend service in europa
alles für die gleiche domain also dns ist die einfachste variante anycast loadbalancing
ist die coolere variante so sieht es aus so guck jetzt habe ich acht server am start jetzt
machen wir das gleiche noch nicht wie heißt das neue hier ich zeige euch jetzt so mal
dass es funktioniert hat ich habe jetzt easy hoch skaliert von von zwei backend servers
auf acht backend server brauche ich den neuen namen von meinem von meiner monitorin kiste
alles funktioniert monitorin kiste steht aber grafana was grafana an ich hätte eigentlich
laufen lassen können wir eigentlich blöd dass ich nicht laufen lassen habe aber ok
admin admin das grafana password exzellent jetzt muss ich das ganze noch mal einrecht
natürlich bescheuern data source ttp weil es blöd dass ich dass ich überhaupt gelöscht
habe hätte ich gar nicht müssen explore browse ne explore
und jetzt habe ich auf einmal ihr seht es hier schon und jetzt habe ich auf einmal acht
backend server drinne siehst du schon vom neuen ne noch nicht jetzt habe ich auch mal
acht backend services drinne wo ich jetzt ram auslastung und alles mögliche schon überwachen
kann und ohne dass ich irgendwas von hand konfigurieren musste das ist halt echt die stärke von solchen
tools und ihr seht ich könnte aus acht jetzt ohne probleme wieder runter gehen auf zwei
oder hoch auf 32 und es würde einfach funktionieren weil sich an der eigentlichen logik nichts
ändert und das sind wirklich die stärken von solchen tools weil es kann ja noch deutlich
komplexer werden ist schon nice man müsste zugeben jetzt kann man beispielsweise auch
cpu auslastung oder solche geschichten leute leute heißt es leute heißt nicht cpu ist leute
eine minute laut guck da sieht man auch den die cd cpu auslastung meiner cloud vms jetzt
natürlich wird man sich jetzt ein cooles dashboard machen und sowas ja klar können wir uns auch
mal wir machen es mal richtig cooles dashboard ninox node exporter default dashboard genau
ich war richtig richtig big brain dashboard da stehen die leute drauf dashboard hier copy
copy id wie ging das jetzt noch mal dashboard wie geht das mit dem weiß dass jemand aus
kopiert das mit dem importer dashboard überhaupt funktioniert dashboard irgendwo hier gär
auf fack wie gewinnt wie konnte man noch mal im kraftfahrer zeug importieren das stand import
da
ach hier ok easy import und hinter ist import so guck mal jetzt haben wir richtig grazes
dashboard was ich jetzt im hintergrund zeigen könnte und sagen schaut mehr was für ein
tolles tolles monitoring setup habt guckt jetzt habe ich meine acht backend server drinne und
kann mir als alles mögliche zu angucken und das alles automatisch konfiguriert das ist
schon nice ja und wenn ich jetzt auf 32 server hoch gehe habe ich instant 32 server oder
runter auf zwei habe ich zwei drinne und da ist jetzt wirklich der ganze miss drinne also
so so viel miss drinne man gar nicht braucht hier memory info memory active cpu auslastung
ich kann übrigens zeigen dass das funktioniert wir gehen jetzt mal auf den wir gehen jetzt
mal auf den ersten wir gehen jetzt mal auf den ersten also auf die zwei auf die null
punkt zwei auf die hier und machen da beispielsweise mal etwas last auf google ich muss gleich
essen ich sehe schon 70 leute instant weg ihr müsst jetzt alle essen oder ich glaube das
ist es echo keine ahnung 2 hoch keck weh nach bc das tacks er war das e drinne ok das war
echo 2 hoch blub blub blub blub ach bc top also wir sehen die cpu ist 100 prozent ausgelastet
und gucken wir mal auf unsere auf unser monitor hier mal gucken wann es das checkt bin ich
auf der richtigen kiste 0.2 0.2 ok unser monitor sollte es jetzt eigentlich bald mal checken
dass sich die cpu was ist denn das da um cpu basi busi refresh dashboard alle fünf sekunden
jetzt müssen wir erstmal wir machen mal die letzte letzten fünf minuten ok letzten fünf
minuten sieht das von deutlich besser aus die letzten fünf minuten geht das geht das
hoch und wenn ich jetzt hier cpu guckt jetzt sieht man auch die cpu die hoch geht die geht
jetzt einfach hier ein cpu kern ist komplett voll zwei kerne hat das ding also sprich jetzt
seht ihr kann ich live im monitor hier schon sehen bei mir dass meine kisten gerade oder
meine kiste etwas ausgelastet sind weil wenn ich jetzt mal rüber gehe auf den anderen
dann sieht man der hat überhaupt keine auslastung aber der wo ich gerade das bc gestartet habe
ist voll am eskalieren gerade auf einer ich gucke gleich ich gucke mir gleich die sachen
im chat noch an so sieht das aus es hat es hat halt schon es hat echt seinen charm dass
das so automatisch sich registriert alles hast du jetzt eigentlich einen neuen job ja
ich habe heute also und ich habe den vertrag schon eine weile da aber heute kam die allerletzte
zusage dass auch der betriebsrat zugestimmt hat das heißt jetzt ist das ganze auch rechtskräftig
und alles und ja jetzt ist jetzt ist die sache unumstößlich ab ersten vierten neuen job
so früh mit dem neuen pc ja bis jetzt schon ich habe so viel damit gemacht 46k als automation
engineer it admin ok bis sie wenig bis sie wenig also es bis sie wenig es kommt natürlich
ein bisschen auf die region und die branche an aber es erscheint mir etwas gering kommt
natürlich auch darauf an was du im endeffekt machst stelle an sich sagt nichts wenn du
den ganzen tag windows assistenten durchklickst wo 50 millionen andere leute gibt die das auch
können keine ahnung aber es erscheint mir ein bisschen wenig insgesamt wie viel berufs
erfahrung hast du schon also wenn es jetzt ein junior einsteiger job ist dann würde ich
sagen das geht in ordnung auch wenn sie ein bisschen mehr sein könnte aber als als zwei
jahre ja da kann da da kann schon ein bisschen mehr drin sein das finde ich ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen wenig aber es ist anscheinend windows ich weiß nicht habt ihr eine idee
was meint ihr was ist besser bezahlt gehen wir mal von so einer 0815 admin position aus
was meint ihr kriegt man mehr geld linux oder windows ich habe echt keine ahnung ich
würde jetzt sagen im prinzip wahrscheinlich ungefähr gleich wenn es nach mir gehen würde
würde ich natürlich sagen eindeutig linux leute sollten mehr verdienen windows wird mehr
gebraucht du meinst es ist dann knapper das könnte das würde ich gar nicht mal sagen
dass windows mehr gebraucht wird im client im client bereich auf jeden fall da hast du
recht aber servotechnisch weiß gar nicht also bei uns läuft alles mit linux außer halt
active directory für windows klein ansonsten läuft bei uns alles mit linux beim neuen arbeitgeber
ist es ähnlich da läuft auch sehr fast alles mit linux das ist prinzip die welt läuft
auf linux so software als tochter also ganz ehrlich die haben genug geld ja kleinzeitig
sind die windows lastig server seitlich ist das alles linux das stimmt mittelstand wo
das meiste der administrationstätigkeit daraus besteht zu gucken dass das laptop und der interne
windows share funktioniert das ist natürlich klar davon rede ich ja nicht also insgesamt
bin ich schon der meiner könnte könnte ein bisschen mehr sein also wenn du wissen willst
was ich kriege kannst du den anfang des streams angucken ich bin jetzt nicht dass es so rüber
kommt so nach dem motto alter max erzählt uns zu jeder gelegenheit da was er für fette
kohle verdient ein richtig für den sub sorry die ich übersehen habe heute guck mal kurz
creator dashboard was habe ich übersehen ich muss gleich essen leute der lumpen meckes
hat subscribdach vor den habe ich gesehen danke danke leute was würdest du gehen in
welche richtung von alles bisschen wenig also ganz ehrlich ich meine zwei jahre ist jetzt
nicht die welt ja aber wichtig ist dass man irgendwie eine gewisse perspektive hat also
ich würde schon sagen dass man mal so ein plan machen könnte dass du auf 60 70k kommst
in den nächsten paar jahren ich meine jetzt nicht gleich im nächsten jahr aber dass man
halt vielleicht mal so auch eine gewisse zukunftsperspektive hat also 50 auf jeden fall das kann man damit
zwei jahre erfahrung und wenn man gut ist in dem was man macht und das werden sie ja
wahrscheinlich gesehen haben dass du da ahnung hast sonst hätte ich nicht genommen kann man
schon durchaus fordern aber wenn du mal sagst man somit wenn du das dann anpeilst dass somit
wenn du noch mal zwei jahre am start bist dass du mit vier fünf jahren erfahrung so
richtung 60 70 k gs finde ich durchaus nicht übertrieben in der heutigen zeit suchen alle
händeringen admins und beziehungsweise generell it experten admins anwendungs entwickler architekt
alles alles IT technisch wird heute gesucht wie verrückt und da müssen die halt durch
ich denke die können nicht erwarten dass die leute immer von apple und ei arbeiten und
sich richtig viel mühe geben da müssen sie halt damit klarkommen dass sie entweder wenn
sie nicht ordentlich bezahlen wollen oder scheiß arbeitsbedingungen haben kann ja mehrere
kunde haben dass sie keine gescheiten leute kriegen die halt nichts auf die reihe kriegen
oder wenn sie gute leute haben wollen dass sie gescheite arbeitsbedingungen bieten müssen
und ordentlich geld und wenn sie es nicht machen dann wird es halt nichts wie ist wie
ist die erfahrung im chat mit gals angaben bei step stone also das eine was ich mir da
angeguckt hat mal im stream das war jetzt nicht so wirklich akkurat nächstes jahr wird das
jahr das linux desktop ja bestimmt bestimmt bestimmt jedes jahr nächstes jahr wird wahrscheinlich
noch am ehesten das jahr des linux desstops seitdem es dieses meme gibt weil wsl wird
immer verbreiteter wsl mit grafik support wird auch immer verbreiteter und die ganze
steam deckgeschichte und sowas auch also in irgendeiner art und weise wird nächstes
jahr wahrscheinlich so viel linux desktop sein wie noch nie vorher gewesen ist aber
das jahr des linux desktop wird es wahrscheinlich nie geben hält ja schon daran flach dass
es den linux desktop an sich gar nicht gibt chat ich muss essen gibt es noch irgendwas
wichtiges noch drei minuten irgendwas super wichtiges was wir jetzt klären müssten
sonst machen wir das nächste mal weiter
ich wünsche euch allen ganz viel pepo fett ich habe alles gelöscht ja pepo fett und
ordentlich futtern und und geschenke und zeug was es auf weihnachten alles gibt wann nächstes
jahr morgen wahrscheinlich mal sind jetzt feiertage und das werden sie nicht machen
microsoft bringt kein linux desktop die sind noch nicht mal in der lage mit maui linux
überhaupt zu supporten auf dem desktop also maui anwendung unter linux gescheit zu supporten
also wir sehen uns leute machts gut bis denn see you